if you haven't done any training you
will not do it in a race yeah it's that
simple no you just got to put the hours
in and then it all comes together on
race day right well you know what it
doesn't you know it doesn't
I'm gonna say that today's guest is the
world's most versatile professional
endurance athlete his name is Cam wurf
this is a guy who has distinguished
himself at the highest most elite level
in three distinct Sports first in rowing
where he represented Australia in the
2004 Athens Olympics but then he turns
his sights on professional cycling and
over the years becomes a super domestic
for team sky and now team ineos he's
famous for not only leading team Ennis
to Victory on the cobblestones of Perry
rubé last year but celebrating that win
by going out and running a half marathon
right after the race he can set bike
course records at the world's most
prestigious Iron Man's and he can even
run a 245 marathon after a 2.4 mile swim
and a 112 mile bike if I'm capable of
dreaming something then it's possible an
athlete can do anything I don't really
believe that he can dream something that
isn't possible cam doesn't ever seem to
get tired he absolutely loves training
he's always smiling and I just got so
many questions final note we recorded
this episode quite some time ago all the
way back in February so since then cam
has bookended an impressive slew of
races for ineos with a Podium at Iron
Man Lanzarote and it seems he's just
getting warmed up so strap in and let's
do it this is me in the great cam Warf
this episode is brought to you by
timeline nutrition which is this new
skin health line of products check it
out you can get 10 off your first order
today a couple of guys met us for a ride
one guy Belgian guy works at the Rafa
shop I can't remember his name but I
feel terrible because he he rode against
me in 2001 at the junior worlds he was
in the Belgian four and the going into
it we'd done a couple of lead up Junior
right we were the two top ranked Crews
everyone was you know was like who's
gonna win and we're in the semi-final
and we're on the start and just one
we're in Germany and one of those random
storms like you know they just they have
those sirens on the end of lakes in
Europe and like they know that
something's coming in so they've worn
the siren it goes and next thing this
thing just like rips through there's
white caps everywhere and stuff getting
blown all over the place one came one
was coming and our coach could see it he
was trying to get my attention because I
was in the stroke set of the boat to
like pretend I'd broken something in the
boat to get a delay and I was like he's
waving you know I was like you sort of
ignored anyway sure after race started
we got about 100 meters and boom this
thing hit us and we were all quite small
like 150 pound kids and we're racing
Romania Belarus that were you know 300
pound men yeah probably with fake
passports and uh sure enough like they
just sat back and leaned into it and
just plowed through this storm and you
know made the final we missed out by one
spot and the same thing happened to
Belgium in the next Heat and um or sorry
in the heat before because they'd headed
towards the end of their race and so we
ended up both in the B final but we beat
them in the B final and uh he reminded
me of that you know we should have been
first and second that year I was like
yeah well you know we were seventh and
eighth
[Laughter]
so this Belgian guy who works at the
Rafa shop here in Houston
yeah is that like the first time you've
seen him in 25 years or whatever yeah it
was it was 2001 it was 22 years ago wow
and and not only that but I'd done some
efforts before he arrived and I mean
they weren't hard they were like some
zone three just efforts I was doing
around 410 watts and he said how do you
feel you know at your age like he's
obviously working I'm still in different
sports and and he and I said you know
what it's funny like even when I was
rowing and we'd get on the bike like if
you could do 400 watts for like 20
minutes at you know 70 kilos 150 pounds
that was pretty a pretty solid effort I
said well mate 22 years later it still
is
that feeling has not changed and I said
I can't even believe I'm still doing it
but uh I am and I and you know and I and
I apply myself the same way I did 22
years ago right you know I I just love
it I love
I love exercising yeah and you're what
are you 39 yeah no 39 39 but you're
you're still improving every year yeah
um you had a cup you know during covid
you were sort of
angled for a Peak Performance but there
were no races yeah but you've bounced
back and you put in your best uh Kona
performance this past year it just so
happened to be an incredible field and
all kinds of Havoc broke loose with yeah
not just the Norwegians but Sam laidlow
yeah you improved on your bike course
record by three seconds that he
demolished me but you know it was almost
like I was watching the live stream yeah
and you were barely brought up in the
whole conversation it was insane which
is I mean that's how you want it you
know I mean when I took the record I
took it off Norman Stadler who had
stopped racing you know centuries ago
and
Sam what impressed me most was I was
there and I was powerless to do anything
about it you know I was I mean in
admiration and and of what he did as
much as everyone else watching I think
you know I was really pleased for him
he's a lovely he's a lovely guy at the
at the end of it all and that was uh his
first Kona right that was his first Kona
and the Norwegians their first Kona yeah
to come in their first time out yeah
basically rewrite the rule book
completely there's all this lore about
how you can't do that yeah right and
they're just like I don't care about
that like I'm just gonna go in and crush
and they did yeah uh how does that I
mean for somebody who's who's been so
enthusiastically pursuing a win at Kona
for so long yeah does that now feel
daunting like it's definitely a seismic
shift in where the sport is headed yeah
I mean not really it's uh it's kind of
getting towards the level I assumed you
know you'd want to get to and I've been
aiming to get to and it I thought about
this on the drive out like thinking back
you know through what I've done and
I've forgotten who it was you had on
here but it was a guy talking about I'm
in Canada and he didn't
get to really speech that he planned to
read
um
I listened to that I was running in
Maryland I remember my wife's families
from over there I was in the middle of
nowhere at the podcast on
and I I guess it was it was it sort of
resonated with me because I've never
feel like I've been able to empty the
tank in an eye man
and through a range of reasons the first
time I won one was in 17 and and I'd
qualified for Kona a few weeks before in
the last qualifying race and we'd
already planned to like do the Iron Man
Wales because it helped for the next
Kona to qualify so we like bugger you
might as well go anyway just do some
training anyway sure enough it was a
horrible day I was miles in front of the
bike I was basically able to walk the
run and win and great and then obviously
came to Kona that was when I first broke
the bike course record and kind of
established myself in the sport
19 I won twice you know the first one
was in Port Macquarie and it was the
first time I could run properly so I was
running quite well got nervous halfway
through because I was running quicker
than I've ever run so I started eating
too much so then I had to slow down
because I had stomach cramps you know so
that kind of I still won but it was
nothing then I did Iron Man Italy later
that year and I was in I made you know
ready for Kona but it was three weeks
before and we basically did it to test a
new bike but I was sort of so far in
front and felt so good in the first half
of the run it was like I might as well
finish it off the gas but yeah I took my
foot off the gas but still run 244 I
think I went 7 45 that day and then Kona
was three weeks later and while
physically I think it was maybe still a
good decision as far as training goes
what we didn't counter was it's on the
other side of the world travel so by the
time I had a few days off before Italy
traveled to the other side of the world
dealt with jet lag dealt with different
climate all of a sudden you get to the
start line and it was like a month since
you've trained you know and I was fifth
which was a grind out you know it was
the best result I've ever had but I
finished it going gosh you know I think
we got that a bit wrong anyway
and then of course we had um you know
Copenhagen in 21 you know we had covert
then covert hit so it's Copenhagen in
21.
great Ray miles in front on the bike had
Lionel quite a ways behind 10 11 minutes
I was like okay this would be fun I just
watched keep showing gold at the
Olympics in the marathon I love the way
he just booted away from everyone so I'm
gonna go nice and slow and then when
Lionel gets within you know 30 40
seconds I'm just going to Ping it and he
caught to that I don't know three four K
from the end so then I just went for it
and put like five minutes into him you
know it was it's quite comfortable then
Kona got canceled right and so you feel
like basically the point being that you
feel like you've never been able to drop
the hammer and have a race that you're
capable of having no like the one I've
envisaged having and then finally this
year with Kona you know I had the chance
to train until the week before I felt
like this was going to be the moment to
finally like get it all out you know and
and then uh yeah it just didn't happen
right well you shared with me something
just before the podcast about what was
actually going on that I don't know if
people know about that no I haven't said
anything because you don't want to make
an excuse and it's not an excuse it's
just you know it's amazing how it it was
covered you know and and I I got sick
three four days before I started
noticing it I think as people know I'm a
bit of a Nutter for training I love
training and that last week is for me is
the worst week you're not meant to do
much and I found myself cutting not
doing much short you know it was very
uncharacteristic couldn't sleep properly
I I said yeah I knew there was something
wrong I you know I was taking
paracetamine whatever anyway I was like
look if I can be on that start I'm going
to be on there you know and sure enough
I raced yeah I was I was off the pace I
was never able to get into the race it's
quite achy and and didn't it was it was
a real you know another grind
um and the result was what it was and it
you know a couple of days later the team
you know sort of encouraged me to do a
test
um because they were you know we had a
carer there at the race Marco who had
sensed there was something a bit up and
um
yeah sure enough had covered you know
and I was I was negative a couple of
days later and I guess the thing for me
was I'd been so diligent for that whole
period because with the team and the
bubble you know you can't you know go
outside like I I'd sacrifice swimming
and running and stuff at races which was
I was meant to be able to do as
preparation for all that time to make
sure I didn't get anyone else you know
risk getting anyone else sick or bring
it into races and never had covert I'd
done hundreds of tests maybe thousands
you know and then when it was finally my
chance like it was finally my moment you
know I I guess I got over there and just
got so excited to be amongst it all and
and I'd never had it so I guess I was
maybe a bit more susceptible I'd train
really hard I was probably really on the
razor and and it got me you know it had
um but uh you know and afterwards you're
like ah I mean initially after the race
I was like well that's really there was
a real tough pill to swallow obviously
what Sam did did what the boys did I
wasn't even part of the race I didn't
even feel like I was involved yet I was
still 11th and went eight hours
um I you just I didn't really know I was
sort of I guess well blow cycling you
know that's just get stuck into this
again let's just focus on one thing
but then when I found out I had covert I
was like well you know what that's not
that bad and um yeah I mean it's
encouraging actually you you you you I
mean it's it's a weird thing because you
go eight hours you break the bike course
record yeah that's a phenomenal effort
yeah but you had to go under eight hours
to break the top ten yeah it's just an
unbelievably fast feel but then to
discover even if it was a low-grade
version of covid that you were competing
with covid yeah once again you've been
unable to be at your best yeah when it
matters most I think I said to you like
I ran with the boy the Norwegian guys a
couple of days later and that was sort
of when I figured it must have been
something because Christian made a
comment of how come good I looked you
know he was running like he could barely
move and I was if it looks so deceiving
with that guy true true very true but it
was just so stiff and sorry could barely
walk and he said you know you're not
even you don't even look tired and I
said well to be honest I I just didn't
feel like I could get out of first gear
all day you know I just wasn't in the
race I couldn't get to you guys I
couldn't
be a part of it and didn't know why and
it was that night that I did the test
and
yeah so of course you know I was
disappointed I really wanted to fight
back quickly you know I was I was
negative quickly which meant that I'd
probably had it some time before the
race so it'd probably been affecting me
for longer than I've I've realized or
I'd been able to ignore
and wanted to do another race at the end
of the year you know Arizona Israel you
know Cozumel something you know just to
really have that that big tank empty you
know and um yeah I tried to get back
into training and just every time I
tried to train I just get sick again so
you know I was worried about chronic
fatigue fortunate it wasn't that that
just I got some advice said you just
gotta rest you know it's not smart to do
an Iron Man with that virus
um so you read to and hope that you
haven't done any damage you know that
was the big thing for the team they were
worried about your heart and did quite
extensive tests on me once I was healthy
and I seemed fine and and to be honest
now I feel fantastic you know I'm I'm
able to train at a level I haven't
trained at in the past and
yeah it's just uh hopefully that me
getting covered was the end for everyone
that was like the page Turner for the
for the rest of the world we can all
move on now okay thank you for giving
the world permission I took one for the
team
that's good to know I mean when when you
say you know the team was concerned or
the team did this you're talking about
ineos which is the cycling team that
you're that that you compete on behalf
of so yeah
um you know just to kind of create some
contacts for people who don't know who
you are uh you compete for the world's
greatest cycling team the most
successful most dominant professional
World Tour cycling team you also compete
as an individual as an elite Iron Man
triathlete and you seem to do this with
with it appears relative ease and parody
like it's not as if one is a side hustle
and one's the full-time job yeah they're
kind of equal footing I you know I feel
like you have perhaps a greater passion
for Iron Man particularly Kona and
Triathlon
um but it's the stability of being part
of this team and and perhaps the
camaraderie and the kind of foundation
that that provides you and your family
and also your training yeah to kind of
you know root you in something so that
you know you can do all these other
things as well like it's a complicated
puzzle I'm sure yeah but you're the only
one who's doing this yeah are you the I
think you're the only one who's ever
done yes right I mean there was
tolansky but he he stopped yeah he
stopped and you know he was a pro
cyclist for slipstream for I don't know
six or seven years right yeah I became a
pro Iron Man yeah you're the only one to
try to do them simultaneously yeah and
as far as I know yeah and I uh my Big
Goal you know sort of you know uh last
year for example of 2021 was uh to win a
race and win an Iron Man you know and I
was able to do it or be part of a
winning team you know part of a winning
like guys winning the first year in 2020
I was never part of a win with the team
you know we had a bunch of seconds even
second in the world to be rich in car
repairs like was a great fight with
jumbo vizma but didn't win and then so
21 I was like right I want to be part of
you know a win and thanks to Tom Peacock
at his first win and I was there for
that
um and then obviously Bunch followed
that and then I went in Copenhagen you
know and then
last year in 22 part of more team
victories but didn't quite you know I
couldn't win one myself I was second in
the one-eyed man I did aside from the
world championships in um in uh in
Victoria yeah inventory against Spain
right I got beaten by 30 seconds but you
know that was I'll see your point you
know they had me actually the week
before it was the Tour de France started
the weekend before they had me in
Copenhagen for some VIP you know stuff
but also covert was still quite Rife
like just in case you know if they had
to throw me in I was there
so I obviously wasn't there preparing
for an Iron Man and then when I didn't
get to race the tour it's like wow you
got to qualify for Kona now okay there's
a race next weekend off you go so rest
home throw all the stuff in the car off
I went and I almost pulled it off you
know I actually had a pretty good swim
you know a good lead on the bike and
was nursing myself through the run and
got caught in the final part but um
yeah I've learned that it you know the
the guys are very very good in both
Sports and so I need to be more I'm not
sure what the cup compartmentalize I
mean that's mental but basically
dedicate myself specifically to each you
know at certain times to to do it
properly because otherwise I just become
okay at both and and I don't want that
like I can go to a bike race and do my
job for the team and you know Gene I had
this conversation in training the other
day yeah
Tour de France yeah yeah he's out here
training with me and it was if I if I'm
on the front or you know protecting the
guys or helping them for 5K longer than
we thought that's great if I'm there 5K
less
they work it out you know it's it's not
really it's no big deal take a break
it's me that knows whether I gave it all
and did it actually made a big
difference or not like me personally so
when I don't do a good job you know if I
have been you know kind of doing too
much running or whatever and it's
affected me you know racing on the bike
it's actually a loss because racing on
the bike provides an amazing opportunity
to push my body way harder than I would
like to because it's one of those Sports
where you just have to go as fast as the
guy in front which is something I feel
can be a weapon to take back to you know
Triathlon and periodically I've been
able to get that right over the last few
years but not consistently and so
and a lot of that has been because of
this whole covert thing with the bubble
I haven't been able to go swimming I
haven't been able to go to the hotel gym
and go for a run during the race see
just a small you know even just a small
one just enough to keep as you know
assuming you know the swimming thing has
got to be tough right like you're in
Europe you're doing these races you're
not you know like you're not gonna find
a pool all the time no and and
swimming's the one you need to keep the
fuel for and so for me just being able
to get in the pool even just at the end
of the day for a kilometer or two it
would make a massive difference to
having 10 days off because otherwise you
tend to go home and it's like you're
starting all over again for someone like
myself without a swimming background and
anyway and so again I was thinking
though but it's bizarre because even on
a bad day I still swim with like you
know Lionel or Sam long or kinlay or
these guys
and but I don't actually yeah it's when
I'm not don't even get to train you know
I know it's insane so insane that you
you can basically the way that I
Envision it and it's probably not like
this but it's sort of like you're in
Europe doing whatever you're doing with
the team uh and and you're sort of on
standby as a domestic or a super
domestic you don't always know if you're
going to be enlisted to do this race or
that which makes it difficult for you to
plan your race schedule with respect to
Triathlon it's kind of a standby thing
right so you're always sort of training
but not really sure what you're training
for yeah and then you're like okay well
I'm gonna scoot out and do this Iron Man
and you you parachute into some race
yeah after not having swum at all yeah
but somehow you're able to stay in
contact with the lead group yeah water
yeah like what is going I mean the
French skills for me to get from
selecting these Bunch skills the
craziest example maybe there's a crazier
one but the one that struck me was in
was it I get all the dates confused but
right before St George you're a pair
like the most insane brutal one-day
cycling race there is yeah and you're
you know on the lead out in the cobbles
basically blazing the pass for the team
yeah and and really set the team up for
a win yeah and then you basically split
from there and drop in on St George yeah
and Lead that race on the bike toad you
basically towed Christian the whole way
and set him up for the win yeah but the
fact you didn't even think that you were
going to be doing that race right
because you were supposed to be doing
something else for ineos yeah yeah so
you weren't even really preparing for
that well I actually had to go to Africa
the following week so it's like can I
feed it in or not and I decided last
minute well I can so I'll go so I came
here then I went to Namibia and then she
did a it was another corporate bonding
thing they wanted me to do
um over there but you know it's funny
like back to when I stopped you know I
was doing a similar role and Peter Sagan
was my teammate at Cannondale and and I
guess I got to I guess I was 30 31 and I
was like wow my productive years as I
like I'm this is great I'm a domestic
you know I'm a big team and blah blah
blah but I don't want these I don't want
to waste my productive years doing this
so that's when I moved to the US I still
had a contract Fortune with Canada which
they honored and um gave me a bit of
time to you know find what I wanted to
do I really wanted to work in finance
I met a bunch of different people in
that field and finally found you know a
place I wanted to work down in Century
City
um with a real estate investment firm
Mosaic was just sort of starting out and
um anyway it was I did I was there for a
little bit you know starting to study
and Ethan the the the founder of it all
you know he said why would you you know
you could be in sport you know do you
want to go back to me rowing do you want
to go back to so I was like no you know
I'm really happy doing this and I'd done
a couple of triathlons for a bit of fun
and so I said oh but I enjoy this and as
only an American would he said I used to
live in Kona he said you can beat those
guys I used to watch that race every
year you're better than them and I'm
thinking mate I've done a couple of
triathlons for fun like only an American
would say that to you and so I kind of
you know I took one seriously it was
Arizona as a pro I said if I can get off
the bike you know quicker than yarn had
had set the world record in Roth the
swimming bike combined I'll think about
learning to run and
anyway it just sort of snowballed from
there I was able to do that I just
hobbled through the run I didn't even
bother training for the run for that one
it was all about the swim in the bike
I went back to Australia for a bit of a
break you know before I'd come back and
I thought I'd just get into Finance you
know got a random call from Chris Froome
to do some training down there because
he was holidaying I thought why not and
um yeah
if you're a Gen X dude like me then skin
care can feel a little indulgent but I
actually wish that I didn't wait until
my 50s to take care of my skin a little
bit better because hey it's our largest
organ it's essential to health and it's
our first line of defense against
environmental aggressors the fact is as
we age our mitochondria generate less
energy so anything that you can do to
boost these little power plants is
absolutely huge timelines worked it out
in their nutrition products and now they
figured it out with skin care cracking
the code with this new product called
mitopure which is a patented version of
a postbiotic that they've discovered
helps rejuvenate mitochondria and
promotes healthy skin it's packed by 15
years of clinical research they've got
three products the day cream the night
cream and the serum I've been testing
them and using them I'm really enjoying
it I do think my skin looks better and
it looks more refreshed it feels more
refreshed and you should check it out so
to get you started timeline is offering
10 off your first order click the link
in the description below and use the
code Rich Roll
to the offered all right back to the
show
just so I so the audience is clear let's
let's like really establish what exactly
happened here which is essentially that
you you start out as a rower you're from
Tasmania yeah you go to the Olympics in
2004 yeah in the um the lightweight
double skull right Olympian yeah right
Pinnacle of sport for anybody yeah uh
somehow you reinvent yourself as a
professional cyclist and then you spend
how many years like you know a handful
of years as a pro you bounce around
between a couple teams but you're on
Cannondale liquid gas like that's that
was like the main team you were on right
yeah and and from what I understand
there were some sort of discontentment
around like you know how the whole kind
of like Pro cycling thing operates and
and you were feeling dissatisfied with
that and kind of hung it up yeah and
that's where the finance thing came in
yeah so you're thinking my athletic
career is over yeah the boss says
get the [__] back out there what are you
doing yeah and uh you do a couple
triathlons and you go back home and
you're riding with Richie port or you
know one of the greatest cyclists there
is there are you're training with him
yeah and you it was an intimacy yeah
Tasmania yeah and then he goes on to win
tour down under shortly thereafter right
and you kind of set him up for that yeah
you get this call from an old rowing
coach who's now a cycling coach
yeah who's like come ride with Froome
yeah you know the the guy at the moment
he just won the Tour for the third time
right yeah and then you set him up for
more success well you won all three in a
row after he started training with me
yeah you're like the go-to guy like if
you want to win a grand tour you got to
call up cam because he's the secret
weapon yeah so now it's it's Port it's
it's uh it's um Froome yeah and now it's
it's Garen and you know these are the
these are the these are the top guys in
the world and these are the these guys
choose to train with you you're the guy
they want to train with yeah so the
question is like what is it about you
why is it that they want to spend you
know all these hours all this time like
what what are you contributing to those
guys and what are you getting out of
that that is nourishing for you but also
nourishing for them and creating all of
this success well I guess the big the
big thing is we're not competitors you
know I mean I I've always been friends
with a bunch of guys from other sports
uh Jimmy Johnson for example NASCAR you
know and and we I've learned so much
from him and he asked me so many
questions I guess because it's not
confrontational he knows I'm not going
to get in the car or I might get in the
car but I'm not going to drive as fast
as him likely I know he's not going to
do an Iron Man as quick as I can and the
same with these guys you know I mean
they're training for something
completely different but I guess the
endurance element there's a company part
you know I mean I've got a lot of
stories so I can fill in a lot of blank
time so I think the guys enjoy that but
I've always been very good at training
you know and that was part of why I quit
the first time because I could train I
know like the best in the world and I
know now because I'm still training with
those guys but I could never race like
that you know I didn't figure out the
sport you know I just didn't know how to
apply they were trending to train just
because you like training I love
training I love exercising I mean I call
myself a professional exerciser and so
you know that was the thing I went and
trained with through me there you know
it was obvious that I still had a bit
under the hood so then they were like
listen you want to come back to cycling
I said no I'm interested in Triathlon
okay I will support you with that
so you know obviously spend some time
with freemium 17 then 18. Garrett wants
to win the Tour and he wanted to he was
thinking about coming to LA because I
told him during camps the previous year
how great it is here yeah so the team
said oh Cameron can you go and train
with him so you know for sure sure
enough fast forward he wins the tour
that year you know and and it was just
you should get like bonused for that
yeah you know what I mean the thing is
and and this is what Chris said to me
we're in so in 17 we he just won the
Tour and in between the tour and the
Welter which he obviously won as well we
were in chatel training and we'd had a
great camp and at the end of that I had
one last crack at qualifying for Kona
that was in that was in Sweden the
following weekend after we finished that
little camp and the last thing he said
you know before I he said you don't have
to do anything more than you're capable
of you know like just believe in
yourself mate like you belong at this
level and and it was and so training
with these guys day in day out you
wonder why I think I can just like
I mean you'd think I could I could do
that going to I'm not sure what's a
great example but maybe the Malibu try
or you know the El Segundo local
Triathlon like it's one thing to do what
I do and then on the bike and then go
and jump into that but I think oh yeah
okay I'll go on Race through Bay and
then I'll go to the world championships
and I don't even think about it because
I'm surrounded by these guys right you
know at this level the best the best of
the best and I've really never known any
different it was the same in every sport
that I've done you know I've always been
surrounded by
by the best guys and uh
yeah and I guess it's nice that I
finally found a sport that I'm
competitive at and and it is all about
me and if I think about sort of what's
happened in the past years with the team
like you said there's no schedule and I
don't think that's worked as well as we
thought because the idea of me coming
back to the team was I'd be at a
training camp with the guys I'd be maybe
stronger than a lot of the guys on the
camp it's like oh wish we could just
take Cameron you know and I'm like well
you know I'm happy doing Triathlon blah
blah blah Dave eventually said listen
we'd really like you to be on standby
and I thought well that sounds great but
the team manager but the problem sort of
that eventuated the last few years was
then I was all of a sudden getting
called into everything because it's like
oh Cameron's free is he oh we'll take
him oh Cameron's at home oh great well
he can come and do this and all of a
sudden I don't get to train properly you
know I kind of as I said I go home and
I'm restarting my swimming I'm
restarting my running you know there's
no real consistency of blocks so to be
brutally honest the last couple of years
I haven't really felt like I've been
able to
put the work in or perform at the level
I've wanted to in either sport it sort
of hasn't been quite like it used to be
you know are you and so now they've sort
of the team have said right what are we
going to do better this year and and
they're going to limit my racing ideally
to One race a month so I get the time to
train you know train with the guys push
the guys push myself you know get called
into a race to to fill a gap and
whatever and
and hopefully finally get to marry these
two you know Sports because I I love
doing what I do now with the guys but I
think that's because I get to go and do
my own thing right you know all that all
the time I mean the pressure like Kona I
mean regardless of the why I didn't
perform it it's it's still it's all on
you you know and that there's nothing
that can help you with that feeling you
are all alone you know if it's great
great you get to feel all that when
things go I just now feel like I almost
wished I wasn't on the team because a
lot of it was because I felt like I let
so many people down you know I mean I
did what I could but I felt like I let
all these people down I felt horrible
and um and now you know I wouldn't want
that all the time like to be a leader in
cycling and then have to go and do that
yeah that would be pretty intense
balance you answered the question that I
had which is you know whether you in the
back of your mind you think maybe I
should let go of the pro cycling thing
and if I just went all in on Triathlon
and get those consistent blocks yeah in
with the swimming and the running and
and give it the focus that it deserves
yeah
um you could you know like how much
better could you be yeah right it must
it must you must think about that I do
but I also in my mind I picture doing it
the way I'm doing it I just haven't had
a chance chance to do it you know like
I'm going to the UAE next week and like
I know there's swimming pools at every
hotel we stay on the water a lot of the
days so you know the way I see it is of
great I get to race at the highest level
of cycling I'm going to be physically
you know cardiovasively pushed I just
need to go and find some water to flop
around him for 30 minutes just to keep
the motor pattern to then apply that
Fitness to swimming you know the week
after when I go home
um you know there'll be a treadmill I'll
be able to go for a run you know it's
like a one-week training camp with a
cycling focus and then when I go home
right I can switch it back into you know
and and honestly the level of pro
cycling now is it's like Iron Man it is
so high yeah I mean people say what's
the biggest difference when you came
back and you've got to remember I didn't
race for six years until they convinced
me to go back again and
things changed a lot first thing that
was funny was
I just had cycling socks on you know
regular cotton whatever you know like
because that's what you always wore I
got to the start line of my first race
and I looked around
everyone has their own socks on every
single person on every single team and I
thought wow that's that's different
that's already a change yeah and they're
they're cycling is they're sticklers for
their etiquette when it comes to Kit yes
yeah so I definitely were I definitely
stood out but the the one back in the
old days there was much more controlled
you know it was more of a gentle you
know gentleman's agreement a lot of days
so there was a lot of days that were
pretty cruisy and now I and so it's just
like base training all the time pretty
much and I used to you know you chat
away to your mates you hadn't seen you
know I was on an Italian team so you
love seeing Aussies and whatever
I don't talk to a single person when I'm
racing now it's so intense I mean back
in those days was like right we all take
it easy to the feed Zone we all get some
food in the tank and then we race the
last half of the race or the last third
you know and it get but now it can kick
off at any moment you know a bit like
Triathlon you know someone can make the
break at any moment and you don't know
if they're going to come back you know
with the likes of well-man art van der
Pol I mean they just and Sargon you know
started but he was sort of on his own
tangent now there's a bunch of guys like
that and the races are just so
unpredictable and exciting you know well
I I heard these stories I don't know if
they're true tell me if they're not that
in the midst of of stage races like
after a stage you would go running yeah
in the middle of these races and then on
one day Classics you would you would you
would like work out after the race yes
yeah no I have I mean the other day I
raced in Australia and uh we finished
the race and I put my shoes on it was
22k back to the hotel so I ran back and
what are your teammates yeah what did
they make about they really scratched
their head you know and it's not that
I'm I've saved energy or you know I'm
not tired of course I'm tired but I'm
also conditioned to do that and and it's
also and another thing that I'm really
proud of is and not for me but the
respect that the guys have for the sport
now you know they think they appreciate
they respect me you know for for my role
on the team and even in the sport I know
that other teams you know other Riders
you know they give me space they they
respect me in the Peloton and they now
talk to me about you know the Norwegian
guys about lay low you know about about
the women you know Lucy I mean they ask
me questions like they they always
thought oh the triathletes they're just
okay at everything they're like well
wait a minute no because this guy just
led us on the cobbles in Rue Bay and
most of the Field's already been dropped
and then he goes to an Iron Man and he
sort of and he's one
exactly he's not like you know Head and
Shoulders above anyone and and these
guys then get off and run too you know
so like an appreciation for uh the sport
of iron that's a huge shift it is
because you've had people like you
mentioned Andrew talanski I mean he
tried to do it and came in I mean he
never even qualified for Conan never
even looked like qualifying for Kona you
know I mean and it's not because Andrew
is not a phenomenal athlete but I mean
Jay and I were talking about this as
well the other day G said yeah well you
know maybe you are actually good at this
sport
it's not it's not that the Sport's easy
that's funny well well what's
interesting
is
um the parallels between what brailsford
has done with British cycling team sky
and ineos
um uh looks very similar to what olav is
doing in Norway Yeah by you know really
kind of like engineering the sport to a
whole new level through data and testing
and yeah and you know brails for its
whole thing of of you know marginal what
is it called like marginal games yeah
marginal gains and like like what do the
guys think of I know it gets mocked and
all of that but like he really did you
know revolutionize British cycling and
created the most you know dominant team
in in in you know recent memory yeah we
talked about that at the camp about you
know creating the a diet like a team
like a great a great team you know the
book would do great it's like it's a
great team and people say oh how do we
and it's like well it already is because
it's not only you know there was
whatever the eight tour wins but it was
it was seven I can't a lot and but there
were four different guys yeah you know
and and also you plug someone like me in
there okay I'm not winning the tour but
I'm having success in another sport like
you know that to me is a great
organization you know I mean and and if
I look at it from my perspective one of
the biggest things was when I was
getting supported just in Iron Man how
hard all the staff work you know I go to
a camp and you know everything's there
and you just that that culture like the
way Dave chooses the people to work
there chooses the writers everyone's
working their backside off and that
filters through to your training you
know you go out and train you're like
well I'm not going to sandbag today
because
I can see all these other you know Tim
Carris and the coach like our version of
life like he's there every day following
us you know I mean there's just a a
commitment to Excellence across the
board exactly you're compelled to show
up for that yeah and and back in the the
marginal gains was not like the
Norwegian like the science so much you
know there's no
there was no lactate testing or no VO2
testing we've we actually never do any
of that and I will say like unless you
know what you're doing don't do it
you're better off working hard
um but it was like chefs it was you know
mattresses pillow you know things to
help you sleep you know investing
heavily in in massage therapy you know
the best the best carers Etc and but
also I think listening to to him talk
and then comparing it to Tim like the
the way that he kind of he's close you
know as in it's like uh you know of like
a fan you know really keeps an eye on
them very much a part of their lives but
obviously needs to keep a level of to be
able to tell them what to do and that is
identical to Tim Garrison you know like
he was always there he was he's been a
part of all our lives like we've all got
married we've all had kids you know like
he's been you know a part of all that
yet when the time comes he knows when to
say
you got to go and do this you know or or
come down on you or or whatever else and
and also that that most people don't
want all those good guys challenging
them you know I mean the good guys want
to be
but he created that environment where it
was normal for like you know Geron or
frumi or Richie port to be like
proving they're stronger than each other
right yeah you've got nobody's King for
more than a day like it's all it's
nobody's resting on like normally
typically historically in Pro cycling
like if you won the Tour or you know
you're just you can be expected to be
the leader the following year and my
sense is that that's not really the case
no you know no and perhaps you know I'm
that must have caused issues or friction
with you know Froome and Garen at times
and like not knowing who is the team
leader and all of that yep oh absolutely
it did I mean obviously it was Bradley
increased right which was a big one and
and and and then obviously when gear on
one I mean for me was peeved you know
like even this year for Garrett like not
sort of it just feels like he's not
being accorded the respect on some level
yeah I mean it's not exactly
you just got third yeah yeah and he's
not gonna race the tour this year no
he's off to the Giro yeah so I mean
partly a bit of that might be his choice
but again it does come down too well
okay will have to go back to the drawing
board and see how we're going to try and
win it you know and and any other team
that performance would be roof house you
got third right okay that's that's built
on that you know try and get you back to
the top so it's a tension between uh you
know that kind of like ruthlessness that
comes with
uh performing at just you know the
absolute next level of everything yeah
but also a big part of the success has
to be the Esprit de corps like creating
kind of a you know that that team unity
I feel like that's a role that you play
and and probably why you know a big part
of why they want you around like yeah
you're a great exerciser or whatever and
you can you're a great super domestic
but but
um my sense is that like people like
having you around and you you make the
team better just not just by your
performances but also by your
personality yeah I mean there's a few
things person I've always thought like
you know a player that makes the team
great can be is as valuable as a great
player
um and and I've always I always in
rowing want to be the worst guy in the
boat because that meant that everyone
had to be better than me so then we had
a great crew and and same on this I love
being number 30 because the harder I
train the better I am better at 29 29
other guys have to be
um you know but yeah Tom Peacock sort of
nicknamed me you know CMA Chief morale
officer because and and I think that
like Ruby for example is a great example
you know I mean I wasn't meant to do it
obviously
the team was hot you know they were
winning everything and all of a sudden
they decided to send me in I don't know
who it was that made that call you know
thought wow that's bringing the the yeah
I remember like I I went in and um I did
a race during the week and I thought I
was going for that and and the team won
that Magnus Sheffield won that and then
they had the team for rube and then they
you know a couple of days later they
said oh camera maybe just stay a couple
of days just do the Recon just in case
you know and I was like oh why not you
know I've never really seen those
cobbles you know I'll go and check it
all out and you'd never done that race
before
uh I had I'd done it in 2010 but it was
a long long time ago so and back then
you know you had tubular tires and you
know aluminum rooms are very different
you know bikes and it was a very
different memory apart from being very
painful and so it was it was very I was
intrigued to see sort of how it'll work
now with tubeless tires disc brakes you
know a completely different anyway so I
I went did the Recon and then you know
they came and said listen we'd like you
to race if that's if you're happy with
that that's simple I got nothing else to
do on Sunday I might as well and so um
you know you come in and and and it did
I mean I I guess it it provided a
different spark like the team had been
so hot they'd been winning but how do
you sort of keep it there you know and
as it turned out I mean that was then
the last that was the last race we won
that spring so who knows maybe someone
had sensed look the I don't know the
drive is sort of maybe just a bit you
know we need something else to change it
and and I can't I feel like that a lot
when I turn up because I'm not meant to
necessarily be part of the a you know
the first picked but when they throw me
in it's like a different conversation at
the table you know I mean the guys all
seem genuinely happy to see me there and
um
it's like a player coming off the bench
isn't it you know yeah sometimes they
can change the game exactly a pinch
hitter like they come in they can change
the game and yeah I mean I don't want to
bump my own horn or Pat myself on the
back but I kind of feel like I I do have
that opportunity to play that role in
this team just by having a good attitude
you know I mean at the end of the day
we're all good athletes we're all pretty
similar there's not a big difference
between anyone we all train the same we
all hit the same numbers you know we're
all basically the same weight we're on
the same bikes yeah I mean Mike Riley
says it the best doesn't he you know
there's so much stuff out there in sport
and life that you can't control the only
thing you can control is your attitude
and I just try and make sure that that's
a I mean it costs nothing for it to be a
positive one yeah well you definitely
have a positive attitude and and I I
imagine the fact that you can go off and
do Iron Man's and then come back to the
team keeps it fresh for you and it
doesn't start to feel like a slog
because like you know those Belgian
Winters and like I mean it sounds brutal
yeah yeah a lot of it like it's sexy
like oh my God grand Tours and all of
that but the day-to-day yeah of being a
professional cyclist yeah uh especially
when you're not you know a room or a
guarant like yeah it's a it's a hard
life yeah well I went through that I
went through the part of you think you
might become it and then the realization
that you're not and you're just one of
like a good team not a good team you
know and yeah it's lonely you know I I
it was hard to meet anyone I mean your
lifestyle is you're all over the place
and
yeah I mean I I'd had enough and I mean
I'm glad I had the courage to just say
listen that's fine I'm just not cut out
for this it's not it's not I'm not good
enough you know to be where I want to be
and I want to put my effort into
something constructive with my life and
yeah to having and it's and it's and
back to that story about you know Ethan
um who I was going to work with he he's
actually been to Kona every year
obviously to support me you know so yeah
the job offer is still like an open door
I was actually in there he he raised
that fund they sold that fund and and
then uh he's doing one more and I
actually spent the day in the office
with him on Tuesday with the new team
he'd like me to be in you know this one
because obviously who knows how long
I'll compete for but uh I've always
wanted to work or do something in that
world and he obviously is one of my
biggest supporters you know he wants to
see me try and wincona so he's not gonna
say listen come and get in here you
gotta stop strap into that chair we'll
put a bike under the under the chair
under the desk and you can pedal away
obviously Sports to the focus but he's
given me the opportunity to come in at
the foundation part of a new fund which
is you know quite an opportunity with
some great people and and and just have
something different going on in your
brain you know I'm 39 now you know I
don't you go to a race and and the guys
are you know some of them are talking
about Pokemon for crying out loud like
it's a it's a different generation you
know and
uh it's nice to have you know I'm gonna
read you know I read a lot of books I've
actually just started reading yours and
um
I read a lot you know as much as I can
and you know now I'll just be reading
some you know uh real estate real estate
you know Financial reports you're going
to follow Simon garons yeah pretty much
I don't it it doesn't matter if you're
motivated and excited about it I think
that's the most important thing you know
and and continue to learn I mean life's
about learning isn't it well I think you
got a lot more to do in sport and we're
gonna get to next chapters in a little
bit but while we're here in in the
present
um
in what you just shared what struck me
is the fact that on the one hand you're
arguably the world's greatest endurance
athlete from a versatility perspective
yeah like you know the fact that you've
done what you've done in rowing cycling
and Triathlon like it's pretty
extraordinary the only person that comes
to mind that might challenge you for
that Crown is Sheila taramina do you
remember her yeah are you you're too
young probably I was just thinking Born
to Run that that sort of word but it's
not that no no no this was an athlete
who competed in four Olympics in three
Sports wow okay swimming I think she
wanted gold on a relay and then
Triathlon I just went to two two
olympiads and Triathlon and then she
competed in the Olympics in in modern
pentathlon wow which is like where you
yeah whatever you like horse riding
horse riding and you shoot a gun and
it's like a totally different thing
right yeah which is pretty [__]
badass I don't know if anybody's ever
matched that but no in current times in
in certainly in present times like to me
you wear that crown and yet at the same
time you're still like not
the best at any of these things but what
I see and what what I think is really
laudable is a very conscious effort to
surren to always be surrounding yourself
with people that are better than you at
what they do yeah and so you've had this
incredible career where you're in you're
you're like in the company of the
world's greatest in the things that you
love the most and so I guess the
question that I have is like what is it
about those people that make them
special or different when you look at
Froome and when you look at when you
look at garant and you know Richie port
and these guys like is there a
commonality are there themes across uh
the way that these individuals operate
that distinguish them from the others
because you as you said like everybody
weighs the same everybody trains just as
hard yeah certainly there are genetic
differences Etc but from perhaps a
mental perspective or just a a level of
professionalism that they bring to what
they do like what have you learned that
has helped you level up as an athlete
well I guess it really well it hit home
seeing it but if I can just briefly
bring the Norwegians into it and it's
something that I'd actually done for a
long like these marathons they'll do the
weekend before you know I mean I
I often did those sessions everyone
laughed at me you know I was like you
can't do that blah blah blah obviously
they come and do it then they perform
now where I'm getting to that is if you
haven't done it in training you're not
going to do it in a race and what I saw
when I started training with Chris was
that I'll give you an example we're in
Chateau at that camp in between the tour
and the Welter so he's just won the Tour
in pretty great shape I've never seen
him train like that for that three weeks
you know he just was flying you know
he'd recovered well from the tour for a
week and then he just got back into it
and Tim loved devising a race simulation
type effort and it was often a climb
followed by a section that would then
lead to a final climb out of period uh
in the year where most people are taking
a break or doing base training if you're
doing the world tour after the tour
you're like look I've done enough
training yeah I'm just going to absorb
it and I'm going to get to the Welter
and I'll be nice and fresh and I'll have
some string length there and I'll
probably do very well not through me and
so he's he's devised this this workout
it was we went and he's like right Chris
will do this climb he's going to do it
at threshold so you wait at the top
because you know you'll get dropped so I
went up ahead and then there was like a
10K pretty flat section sort of false
flat said now you're going to go
threshold there and he's going to be on
your wheel so he he gets a break but he
doesn't really get a break he's still
going to be around you know 300 350
Watts just holding your wheels so keep
the pressure on and then we're going to
Chuck a right we're going to go up this
brick wall like 20 he's going to go up
there flat out because that's the finish
and it was to simulate the first
Mountain Stage in the Vuelta which
happened to be actually in Andorra where
I live so now I do that climb all the
time so anyway
off I went I went ahead and I'm waiting
for Chris Tim comes up in the car he's
like right he's coming you know get
ready so get ready get in the right spot
got him on the wheel we're coming and
you know we're coming along a road and a
main road and it's about to intersect a
major the major road and it's just like
all we had to do was sort of you know
come on to it you know Veer onto it and
then go along about two 300 meters and
he hit this other climb and next thing
we're a few okay or so from from that
point and Tim goes past and we're like
yeah whatever and we get to this road
this intersection where we start we
better look for cars and there's the
team Sky car blocking the traffic like
here's Park this thing in the middle of
the road like right in the middle you
could not there's cars parked up and
he's standing on the other side like
this like a policeman stopping people so
we just ping it straight through this
intersection these cars honking and
hollering you know I keep Towing through
me Chuck's all right goes up this climb
and I creep up at it moment Pace but it
just as an example it's an example first
you've got a guy here that is so good
yet he's prepared to put himself through
that in training still he's just won
four Tour de France's right and and then
he's he's gone through and done this and
obviously then you fast forward a couple
of weeks first stage of the world so you
know what happens he he didn't win the
stage nibbly won because it actually had
a descent Nibley got back and and got
him in a Sprint but for him he went into
red never relinquished the lead you know
he blew the rest of the field away
Nibley had already lost time
and I was watching on TV just going okay
here we go yeah okay now he's gonna do
this bang you did it you know and and
then obviously with Garrett then after
that you know it was and and even you
know with Richie as well when we'd be
back in Australia with Tim coaching him
um yeah there's just been so many
examples of like this simulated
simulated work
um that you know it's they go to a race
and all they have to do is you know
there's always been this talk of the sky
Train you know we're in Tenerife and we
all lined up and that was before I was
on the team that was when I was just
training with him and I'd have my spot
in the line often it was the first guy
sometimes I'd be stronger than a few of
the guys on the team so I might be two
or three back and it's the full lead out
you know and then you have at the end
you know through me or G or whoever you
know racing it out to the top you know
and and that was common you know Tim
Garrison would would improvise that
which is exactly what life does with the
with the boys you know it's it's if you
haven't done it in training you will not
do it in a race yeah it's that simple
yet these Endurance Sports I think
forever in a day you'd be very
hard-pressed to find people that would
be like yeah I'm gonna go and do that
because it's like no you just got to put
the hours in and then it all comes
together on race day right well you know
what it doesn't you know it it doesn't
so well that would be that's a good
answer that's yeah I think that's a
really good answer I mean basically like
they're
I mean the sh the short version of that
is they're not [__] around no right
and they're very intentional about
everything that they're doing
um and and am I allowed to bring a
seeming one a what a swimming story it's
a bit controversial so that first time I
trained with Chris
I that was when we decided Tim Carrison
said you know we want to come back to
the cycling I said I'd like to do try it
you said okay we've got to teach you to
swim and you've got to remember after
Tim had been rowing coach he went to
swimming and he was with the Australian
Olympic team in Athens Beijing and then
he went to British swimming and then
that's how he ended up in team Sky oh I
didn't know that yeah so he all of his
friends were from perfect for you
amazing so I've trained with Chris you
know and then on the last days like
right I'm gonna draw he lived up on
Mount tambrian which is about 40 minutes
from from the beach and he's like right
I'm going to take you to my friend
swimming coach
a rock up to Dennis cottrell's Squad and
Sun Yang's there
so I get in the pool you know and I
haven't swung really much in you know
years like it's just like it was like
something we're thinking about doing and
I'm I'm swimming with him so that first
year when I'm in Australia I get to go
along and train with with sunyang anyway
one night he was doing two hundreds
and on the last one Dennis said right
he's watch this you know he's going to
go out pretty hard he'll have a look at
the clock with 50 to go and he'll decide
whether he goes for it and he and he
swam like a 146 something you know like
not far off the world record at the time
but you just saw like he got to about 30
meters from the wall you know he'd
obviously had a glance at the clock to
see and the kick and the water just went
freaking everywhere okay and I know soon
Yang's not a great you know there's
obviously been the controversy about him
but it's the same principle and swimming
is I think one of the best examples of
it as you know like those guys they're
breaking World Records in training they
go to a race and they know
they're gonna do it and I just think in
endurance sport there's been some of
these outliers that have been prepared
to put themselves through that because
it's a bit different than hurting
yourself for a minute 46 right you know
Christian good stuff have to go and run
a 240 Marathon yeah
you're like this weird
Forrest Gump type character where you're
like I gotta learn how to swim a little
bit and then boom like you know like
like the most elite person just appears
in your it was a famous person's feet
everywhere you go like yeah the people
show up that you need to like kind of
get you to the next thing like it's a
it's a weird series of happenstances
that have kind of created the lattice
work of your career yeah and Bradley
Wiggins once said to me that you know
until you've got everything lined up
like everything is perfect your team
your family your support you know
Network everything
don't even bother putting everything
into it because you'll never be as good
as you could be
but once you've got that you've got like
two or three years and make the most of
it
and you know I've had to build you know
build my way through another sport you
know pick and you know in another like
the swimming obviously is a bit my
Achilles heel you know in the sport of
triathlon as you know the Dynamics of
all that changes a lot all of a sudden
like a Magnus Title of you know you can
swim quite well he can get to the front
he can be provide app plays cycling you
know if I'm if I swim well in a race I'm
I'm normally on the front foot and it's
it's up to me to kind of lose right if I
swim poorly I don't like what happened
in Kona I'm not even in the race yeah
which is I mean that's new it used to be
you really could get away with it you
get exact suit on and it like yeah it
just cuddles the non-swimmer it does and
you know the gaps you know the Swim's
not long enough to really be substantial
in terms of making a a big difference
but now you really have to be you have
to excel in all three like you can't get
away with it no and and one big thing
was in Andorra we had a we in 2018 we
had a a 50 meter pool that shot it to
repair it spent two years renovating it
and then they had a fire so it just
reopened and it's saying something I've
been waiting for it's like right once
that pool opens I can get into my
swimming what's that put anyway finally
now it's reopened so
I've got a a wife beautiful wife you
know she's studying she's doing a master
where she was until she had our boy at
the start of covert but she's almost
finished a master in holistic nutrition
you know leaves a fantastic lifestyle
and
it keeps the fuel tank you know as
perfect as she possibly can be in the
house you know great support you know
little boy I got this support network of
the team and now I've you know I got
Brett Kirby at Nike that you know does
all my running
um you know obviously is involved with
kipchogee and everything else and
the original one yeah yeah the original
one so he did all that and then of
course he was part of the Union Second
Time Around not not as much that was
more inios what is it worth any else
that they're just I mean that cycling
team formula one kipchogee yeah
yeah I mean Jim just wants to win all
the biggest events yeah yeah so uh and
it's like stuff that he loves Africa I
mean that I think is a lot of you know
the with with Elliot and and they've
also they've expanding that so that's
fascinating you bring that up because
Elliot he's like we've got all these
we've got all the and I'm actually due
to go to eldoret soon there's we've got
all these guys that are great Runners
they can run a 204 or 205 they'll never
win the Olympics but they've got amazing
engines they might be great cyclists so
he said to Jim how about you you know
how about we invest and I think Ellie
had invested in it too in a cycling
Academy and so they've built this Center
up there next to the running group and
they're going to see if they can develop
well yeah I've heard a little bit about
that yeah I think that's like really
cool yeah and when they get injured and
they can't run anymore like why waste
this engine you know I mean you're
talking about
some of the most phenomenal athletes on
the planet right you know so so Jim
loves certainly loves Africa and his
fantastic supports and that way you know
the
the Americans cup thing they've never
won that you know that's like a real the
other one right opportunity for him to
you know fund something and back
something that you know brings that to
Britain that they'd never had before
um and then obviously he's got his
passion in you know other in soccer in
football you know he's now talking about
buying Manchester United
Etc involved in the All Blacks the
cycling team
um but yeah yeah I mean he's just uh
passionate about Sport and
and I think it was a big brexiteer you
know and moved to Monaco and was saving
a lot of money in in tax and he said
well you know what I'm going to invest
all that in sport you know he literally
investors invested billions in British
Sport and so
um you know yeah it's uh we're all very
fortunate to benefit from that yeah um
and thinking about uh
you know what What Makes You Different
like what you're distinguishing talents
are I mean your willingness to suffer
and your love of just you know getting
out there and getting after it like with
just unreal consistency is a big part of
it and
and I you know in thinking about that I
I start thinking about like rowing and
like what you learned as a young person
as a rower
um and then my you know my path in
swimming like I think even even though
like rowing and swimming are very
different sports yeah um one thing that
they they share in common
is that they're like Workhorse sports
like they're sports that reward you for
putting in a tremendous amount of work
and volume yeah and it's kind of insane
because you you literally train like
almost as much as like a tour cyclist
for races that are anywhere from you
know 20 19 seconds to yeah three five
minutes you know I don't know how long
the longest ones in rowing are but
they're not that long six minutes yeah
but you develop this capacity to you
know push yourself uh very hard and you
develop that kind of engine that then
becomes uh applicable in these other
sports like you can kind of you know use
it in different ways and you're the you
know the the shining example of
deploying it in different ways yeah I I
even as a 17 18 year old I used to have
six hours Saturdays you know and we go
rowing in the morning I go home you know
maybe 90 minutes I go home do some
weights in maybe an hour and whatever I
had left I did on the bike you know and
so you know at that age I'd be on the
bike but you know but but row is it's
one speed and so every single satellite
you just come home barely making it I
mean you cross-eyed you have no idea how
to fuel yourself and nutrition and and
whatever else so
that's actually not a great Habit to get
into you know it took a while to learn
that's not smart because then the next
day you destroyed and you you cannot
train but but absolutely I mean in
rowing it's I mean people ask what your
favorite you know what was the hardest
or whatever and I always say Well
they're all pretty challenging but it's
rowing obviously gave me great
Foundation you know and and I think uh
like swimming to have the dedication to
train for that many hours knowing that
you're going to compete for such a short
period of time it kind of makes what I
do now like half the time I feel like I
haven't done enough you know like you go
for a run like today you just you know
you ride for four and a half hours and
do some efforts and go for a run do a
few efforts for an hour and you feel
like oh gosh man I bet I've got to run a
marathon when I race like is this going
to be enough you know where is it when
you're rowing or swimming you know
there's no question yeah you're always
so beautiful you're like why on Earth
are we doing this again today you know
yeah I I still think that I still think
there's a lot of craziness yeah but then
the great thing with rowing like it
really does touch every party of
physiology you know but particularly
that anaerobic capacity obviously and
and that's that's all if you've got that
it's easy to build the other end you
know I mean it's uh if you've got the
hard part you know it's like then you
know the base is the the potential for
the base is so much bigger and so
um yeah yeah that's what builds a VO2 I
mean it was like funny the guys talk
about their VO2 being smaller you know
um as far as doing Iron Man as opposed
to doing itu you know and and it was
very interesting to watch mine like you
know Rowan was here started cycling drop
back and then as I got better I
progressed it a bit
um and now yeah it's sort of Fallen a
little bit but to be honest not a lot
um I guess maybe I train
a bit you know in that zone maybe more
than most guys still
um because I'm used to it I don't know
at a higher Zone yeah potentially you
know I mean you did have a little
flirtation with itu at one point yeah
very very very brief you must have
boosted it back up for that yeah yeah
well I did some hard running and and
everything else but that's just another
sport I mean what those guys do it's
yeah groundbreaking you know I mean it's
uh
but having said that you know if you
come from it you know you've got the
muscle memory I don't have it I was
trying to develop it at like 36 37 yeah
something that I'd never had you know
running that quick or swimming that
quick and but I thought well if I'm a
good triathlete I should be able to do
it
um it wasn't the case and it's it's
fascinating because you're going in
reverse I mean most of those guys you
start with the speed and you build the
endurance on top of that yeah
trying to go back to the the fast yeah
and but it just blew my mind like how
you can and that I I believe I'm pretty
good at Iron Man and can be so bad at
that you know when it's still Swim Bike
Run so
um yeah I won't do any more the various
like body composition changes that you
must have experienced by you know being
in these three different sports has got
to be super interesting I was listening
to uh you talking with Garrett on his
podcast about
um some changes like people think of you
incorrectly as just this oh you know
tour site of pro cyclists World Tour uh
obviously you know excels on the bike
lag but they're not appreciating the
fact that you can run a 240 for a
marathon like you're you know and and
and running there's still so much room
for for you to improve because it just
doesn't get the attention that it
deserves and I know that you're shifting
that with what you're doing with the the
the you know coach and all of that
um but you were talking about how when
you really started to double down a
little bit on on your running that you
actually gained muscle mass on your legs
where you would think going from cycling
legs to more running you're going to
slim down and get actually leaner yeah I
mean it's it's a bit like rowing I was
quite lame then and you you build muscle
but then when you become efficient
you lean out I look at Aleister Brown
he's like a rake or even Sam laidlow
he's quite fine but they swim so you
think how and I in in in swimming I'm
kind of I've come into the sport my lats
have come back my back has come back but
when I'm swimming well I finally start
to you know trim out a bit because you
know I get more efficient in the water
and the same thing when I had to really
apply myself to running back at the
beginning of 19 you know where I was
first doing those 100K weeks I just
actually got heavier I just kept getting
heavier and heavier more muscle mass
more muscle mass and then when I finally
started getting on top of the training
after a few months then they find out
again and so it's I've always remained
around that 70 72 kilometer marker but
the sort of weight just has kind of
shifted you know obviously when I went
to cycling it was very similar you know
you built muscle on the legs and
obviously you lost it up top and then
you find down on the legs as well so I
was able to be a bit lighter then
but now when I came in to obviously
Triathlon as soon as you start swimming
you know your body's like wow I need
muscle so it grows and but you know I'm
starting to get to a point I feel where
I'm getting more efficient and and I'll
start to sort of lean down which is how
I'll get myself to the optimal
composition to be able to do the optimal
race that I dream about doing right you
have to be in this but you've got to be
in this in this state where you're able
to excel as a cyclist down at a
triathlete at any given moment right and
so it's it's not an idealized state for
either of them you have to find like you
know a way of like merging those two
things so that you can I have to accept
that I'm going to be as good as I can be
in cycling
you know I mean to me Iron Man is the
priority that's the one I want to win at
and fortunately you know I can turn up
to a bike race and contribute you know
I'm good enough that I'm better than a
lot of guys that do a similar role
um without really having to do anything
specific to do that you know and to try
and then utilize that
to benefit the Iron Man and yeah okay at
this point I probably haven't quite seen
it having said that you know I've ridden
some pretty quick bike splits and run
pretty well for the past couple of years
or a few years but it's yeah I thought
it'd be easier obviously but I think
covert's kind of changed everything you
know I mean my first race back I did the
race in Australia and then I ran 30k
afterwards and I thought wow this is
going to be amazing you know I'm gonna
this is just gonna be the most perfect
you know like hard brick sessions you
know you do a hard race you're on your
hands and knees and then you've got to
figure out how to run you know and and
then we get that opportunity to run on
really tired really really tired legs
like that's like a real privilege you
know like it's something my peers don't
get to do and if I can train myself to
do that you know get into a race no
matter what happens I'll be ready for
that you know I'll be ready to
absolutely bury myself if I have to to
get into it and then or be prepared to
try and put them under pressure knowing
that you know what I
yo I mean I know I'm taking the edge off
you but that's going to bring you close
to my mark so I can actually race you
now even though I know you're a better
Runner
um so
yeah I you know I mean it now I got to
believe that it's the right thing
because that's what that's what I'm
faced with
the uh the differences in culture
between Triathlon and and professional
cycling are are you know significant on
some level are they not like uh with the
exception of the story you just told
about room and like you know pinning
that climb yeah there's a lot of like
you know five to eight hour rides with
coffee stops when you're a cyclist you
know it seems relatively laid back and
at times maybe from a bird's eye view
not as structured as one might think
yeah whereas triathletes tend to be you
know staring at their garments
constantly and losing their minds over
data points and you know kind of perhaps
not seeing the forest for the trees like
they they it seems the approach seems
very different like how do you think
about that or yeah fitting in fitting in
the day you know like fitting everything
into the day is difficult you know and
that and I think that's another point
you make about the guys that's another
quality those guys particularly have is
you know Chris I've been with Chris on a
general ride you know six seven hours in
Tenerife and we've been going so slow we
get passed by people with panniers on
their bikes like cyclo tourists you know
it's like the day in between his hard
day and it's more like training himself
active recovery you know he's like got
to be on his bike he's got to recover
because he knows a big stage is coming
up and then the next day he'll come down
to breakfast with you know like uh one
of those little gel shot floss things
but he fills it up with like three
espressos because you know for his last
you know super threshold effort you know
he needs a booster like to him it's like
race day you know so you're right I mean
I'd say almost half the time cycling's
pretty relaxed pretty cruisy and when
the guys are like oh do you want to stop
whatever I'm like ah yeah well but if I
don't get going I mean I gotta get to
the pool before it closes or you know I
want to run I've got to run before the
sun goes down or you know so I can
actually make it to dinner but as far as
the technical element of it I mean
yeah I mean they I don't it's it's
strange because it's on com it seems to
be on very different tangents you know I
mean to me uh the triathletes would
worry about stuff that I wouldn't even
think you'd need to worry about and the
cyclists worry about you know numbers
that are whole sort of different level
because that's the level they race at so
to me you'd think like worrying about
you know your efficiency at 300 watts or
something it's like pointless because I
spend all my time with cyclists and it's
like you know that's sort of just given
you know I mean you know it's already
taken care of it's already sort of taken
care of so
um yeah I and and I mean even in Andorra
you know I'm the only one there for a
long time Yarns recently moved there and
and not that I've had much to do with
him but I'm really excited because
Hayden Wild's moving there you know and
I you know probably one of the best one
of Christian's biggest Rivals you know
and good stuff for the Olympics
um and a great guy Faso lives there
right sorry doesn't Yvonne basso no no
he lived in Italy I used to train with
him when I was a liquid gas so where I
lived in Italy I used to train with him
but in Andorra I mean there's everyone
you know Tom pidcock I mean a lot of the
I mean we've got 20 writers from our
team
um that are living there you know a
bunch of movie star guys you know a
bunch of guys from Jumbo I mean every
team track you know Julian Ella Felipe I
mean we've got I mean a bunch of MotoGP
guys it's one of those
great environments I guess probably like
Boulders back in the day where you just
all these everyone's good and you know
the days you sort of feel like oh gosh
I'm a bit tired I don't really want to
do it
you just have to look around see who's
doing it and you're like I gotta do it
you know it has that it has that real
feel for it and so um yeah I've I've
never been I've never really fallen into
the triathlete way of doing things and
I've never really trained with
triathletes because of it I think
because the odd time I've done a couple
of sessions like I've been with yarn or
whatever
it is so different how I do things you
know I mean that's always been the case
for you though right you've always been
kind of not necessarily contrarian but
but pretty clear on on a way of doing
things that works for you yeah that
doesn't necessarily fit any kind of
program or modality that anybody else is
doing like where does that confidence
come from do you even like okay so
you're working with the guy at Nike on
your running but like do you even have a
coach yeah I know it's overseeing
everything what you're doing yeah I mean
Tim Garrison got bit they kind of had a
the whole breaking two the second time
around between Nike and ineos was a bit
of a it was a bit yeah there was there
was you know Nike sort of didn't uh
didn't do it again for because they
didn't feel like you know the reason
they did the first one was to teach
Ellie or to help Elliot believe that he
could run that quick and they felt the
next time he would do it would be in a
race right so when ineos came in and put
it on Nike were a bit blindsided by it
and you know there was a bit of funny
feeling there and I kind of got caught
the crossfires with Garrison and and
Brett so they actually didn't correspond
a lot so you know for I was I'm pretty
much like a uh like an NFL team you know
like offense defense and you know
Garrison's probably got the offense with
the swimming and the riding and then you
know Brett's stuck with the defense and
uh and often in the NFL I hear they
don't really communicate either yeah but
that's not it that's not great for you
yeah it works it does you know yeah I
think it kind of pushes me a bit because
you know Brett's just purely there how
can I make you a better Runner obviously
has an understanding he sees what I do
and everything else right he has a
picture of what I'm doing training wise
but but often even Tim said look that's
make the run in the structure so you
tell me whatever you got going on with
Brett and then I'll build everything
else in around that and yeah and I and
for me I guess like you say this when I
was rowing I hated just being the row I
always wanted to be a bit different you
know I didn't wanted to be the different
one that was how I got in my mind about
one day wanting to do cycling you know I
was just going to change Sports you know
and and prove that I could do it no
I did that and then all of a sudden yeah
I went through that and now back in
Triathlon it's like well I don't want to
be like the rest I want to do pro
cycling too like be a little bit
different and um so I guess with
everything I do if it was like everyone
else I probably wouldn't like that yeah
you know you you've got like uh some
kind of like problem with authority you
know yeah
that you know has you pushing back I
mean I guess what I'm thinking is you
know I've seen cases where in in the
triathlon context let's say you know
somebody hires Jerry to be their swim
coach yeah and then they go out and they
find a cycling coach and then they find
a running coach and they're speaking to
these three different people
independently yeah and those people all
know that one discipline very well yeah
and they know how to get you great at
that yeah but if they're not
communicating with each other this is
going to be a disaster because you don't
have a holistic plan for how to be the
best triathlete you're going to be and
you're going to get injured or you're
going to over train or something's going
to go sideways okay wrong yeah I mean
fortunately I've never really had any
injuries and you know I think we've made
a pretty good impact on the sport you
know I mean yeah so I mean that just
makes it all the more like I don't know
remarkable but also baffling yeah yeah
no it does baffle me too that we we work
it out but like I said I mean it just
means that they're only worrying about
their thing and um
and if I mean they're all like I mean
we're talking about the best of the best
people here too you know it's pretty
easy to trust what they're saying and
believe in it and I think it also pushes
me a little bit too I mean if they you
have one person that was worried oh you
just ran hard so maybe we should back
this off often it's like what am I going
to be able to get through that ride and
then deal with that threshold but you
you find a way you know and and if you
look at where the Sport's going now I
mean if even that race I told you about
you know earlier on that I had to
qualify for
Kona in Spain like last minute popped in
to do it I think I went 752 or 753 that
day like just going through the motions
you know I mean back in the old days
like eight hours was like you said now
in Kona I was eight hours which was
almost never broken and now there's 10
guys ahead of me it's you've got to you
know to be competitive in this sport you
gotta find a way to do it differently
because no one's ever done what these
guys doing yeah you know yeah I mean
I've my best you know time in an Iron
Man when I went 745 in Italy all of a
sudden you know a lot of guys went that
speed and until that point and and and I
love that I love that the people maybe
watch me and they go hard I can do that
you know and as a kid and I think it
came from this I desperately wanted to
go to the Olympics and no one from my
school had ever gone to the Olympics and
Australia isn't the most encouraging
Society you know it's not like like I
said about Ethan how you could win that
racing current even though I barely
don't try a lot of fun no one in
Australia would ever say that to you it
was more like we'd never had anyone at
the Olympics you're too young you won't
make it and obviously that really drove
me to make it like at a young age so I
was not far out of school I obviously
made the team I was able to go back
and I didn't go back with my chest
puffed out like look what I did I went
back proud as punch that I'd been able
to do it but also to show the guys that
look I was as you know I wasn't any
better than half of you guys playing
football and being on the Athletics team
or swim team or you know rowing or
whatever I was doing at the school
struggling through my grades but you can
you guys can all do this and since then
my school has had an athlete every
single Olympics in three different
sports wow your high school my my high
school in Tasmania in Tasmania yeah
that's [__] crazy yeah and it's wow
awesome I love that you know and and so
then as I said when I saw this you know
with Iron Man when I went 745
since then it's sort of like been the
marker that like a bunch of guys like
that's just what they aim to do now you
know it used to be eight hours and all
of a sudden now it's it's that and it's
uh it's I I I've kind of feel like the
guy that people believe that they could
be better than which is fine and
unfortunately it often is the case
I wish I could be the best guy but it's
nice to do it in a way that makes um you
know I think helps make the sport better
yeah I mean that was the sense that I
got from talking to Gustav and Christian
like yeah they went in and it was their
first one and they laid it down and had
these you know historic performances uh
but to them it's like they're looking at
what didn't go right or what they could
improve on and they seem to be you know
I'm sure they're very proud but also
like kind of taking it in stride like
okay well we'll see what happens next
year yeah now we know the course yeah
you know well to be to be fair I mean
when people say how amazing it was and I
was you know a long way because we're
great too they were but when I look at
it I said yeah it's about where I would
expect it to be which is crazy but I
said
even the way I raced you know as I said
I was obviously a bit on the back foot I
wasn't you know quite there but I kind
of expected everyone to blow up you know
like I've on the run like I'll just do
what I did in 2019 I'll probably end up
Fifth you know I started the run in
fifth and these guys all ripped past me
like they did in 19 like I remember
Alastair and Lionel running past and
then they just blew up and I just
trudged along and came fifth this time
no one blew up you know they all they
might have blown up a bit later on but
they and and obviously at the front they
definitely didn't and and people oh it's
just a mate I said well the course
firstly the conditions were great the
course is not that hard you know the
course is quite a fast course yeah if
you have a you know if you've got the
the level of conditioning and if you
think about because of the Tokyo
Olympics one what the biggest one of the
biggest talking points in sport has been
is heat acclimation yeah and to me I
just saw a bunch of people and you had
to watch the women as well that
everyone's just learned how to deal with
the heat so it doesn't affect them you
like it used to like Kona that used to
be the big thing nobody could get their
nutrition straight no one will ever go
there fastest or their best in Corona
like it's impossible you know because of
this
and these guys through science but also
through the age who we are in sport with
you know different things we can talk
about that if you like like the you know
the Forefront now and moving sport
forward endurance sport but heat
acclimation is a big one you know and
and those guys
had that dialed I mean you got the guy
that won in Tokyo for starters and he's
training with another guy so there's two
guys you know knew everything about it
but if they know about it of course all
those other guys and me included I did
training for it you know which I'd never
done before
um and so but they but those guys have
Olaf and like who are you looking to to
help you solve those kinds of problems
yeah well the team I mean it was funny
because obviously we had guys who went
to the Olympics so Tim Garrison had some
protocols I got a sauna at home so I'd
run in the treadmill jump in the sauna
and to be honest I actually didn't do
much for Kona I was doing a lot of it
the year before when I won Copenhagen
when we thought Kona was going to happen
right you know that was that was going
to be your year that was good that was
everything was on track yeah and then it
kind of this last year was quite
dysfunctional and it just never gotten
the got in the groove but it was funny
because Brett you know Brett Kirby I
said well what did you guys do with
Elliot and he said oh we could send you
his jacket if you like like they just
sent him a jacket he just ran into
jacket you know and got warm and that
was how he did he say yeah but he didn't
do that before you know I mean that was
what he did for Tokyo so the that was
that was like a a big revolution in
endurance sport to be honest which is is
is is crazy but it was brought about by
the Olympics and and obviously
um the guys and the girls took that to
Kona and and now it's yeah it's just a
pretty fast course now as it should be
you know if you look at the the and if
there's no wind you're going to see some
of the fastest times so fast I've ridden
that course so many times I mean you
know if you get lucky with the wind even
the climbs don't feel that climbing at
all no no no one is a small chainring no
you know it's and it's just watching it
it just looked like these guys are on
the rivet like the entire time yeah like
there is no breather yeah yeah
yeah we're racing and that was always my
thing with the sport when I came in it's
like I want to turn this into a Race So
it's exciting you know and and when I'm
racing I feel like I'm always racing
because I'm either behind trying to
catch up or I'm in front and I'm trying
to get further in front and then on the
run it's like you know how do you try
and win this thing um you know seeing
guys just bubbling along in the pack you
know and then they run through I mean
there's a reason why I guess there's
only a number of us that people talk
about you know because we we try and win
it you know we try and race the race
you can be smart and you know have a
pretty good success rate as far as
results go by you know playing the game
but um yeah it's it's sporty that he
compete so yeah I prefer to turn it into
a race
what's your sense of the State of the
Union when it comes to doping and
anti-doping as somebody who's you know
look you're in the Pro cycling world the
history of that is what it is um you
know what does that look like now versus
what it was and what does it look like
in Triathlon and what are the
differences
well in theory we're governed by pretty
much the same rules I mean cycling
imposes a couple of extra little
and ethical things that you know they
can't actually test for but you're not
allowed to do it you know like um I
guess IVs is a big one you know not that
we do that in Triathlon but after a
triath you know obviously
you can have one to rehydrate Etc and
it's not frowned upon whereas in cycling
you know you have to but to me because I
started cycling 2007 you know the end of
the Lance and then we had a period there
with some crazy results or not you know
chera like you know Dennis menchoff
DeLuca I remember one Jiro just it was
just insane watching these guys
sprinting against each other
um and obviously a bunch of you know
scandals through there Puerto Etc
the big thing that had to change because
if athletes want to cheat they're going
to find a way to do it you know the guys
that don't cheat are the ones that are
most worried because we if something
went wrong we have no idea why or how to
defend ourselves but the thing that I
saw was it became not acceptable in the
sport to cheat from the athletes you
know it was like okay we're going to
keep an eye on each other now and when
you're doing the wrong thing we're going
to say something and you see it I mean
without having to say any names you see
athletes just disappear or when they get
caught they're not welcome back the way
other athletes are you know some
athletes took a band but it's like look
he's good enough to do it clean he'll
come back to a big team so
let me understand so basically what
you're saying is when incidents occur
instead of it ending up on the front
page of Le keep or whatever and becoming
like a global Scandal yeah you're sort
of ushered to the back of a van and like
no I mean if incidents occur they're
they're dealt with I mean if someone's
positive I mean that's black and white
but it's more
if people send something and they're not
discovered
you know then you you just see athletes
sort of exactly you know they're not
getting caught like they're not getting
caught but people around them no and
then they're sort of dealt with and
dealt with exactly and and that's
because you know you're potentially
affecting 100 jobs you know I mean I
know Jim Radcliffe for example if there
was some sort of issue with us that'd be
it the team be gone you know with with
just one athlete I mean a genuine I mean
I don't think if someone accidentally
had a protein powder that was wrong and
whatever but you know if it was someone
got busted repeal blood doping or you
know something
knowingly trying to cheat I mean rightly
so he'd be out of the sport and I think
that would be the case for most teams so
no one accepts that anymore whereas back
in the day I guess there was some sort
of continuity amongst the processes and
what was going on and what was required
to succeed to get the publicity to get
the sponsors in and the cost of all that
um
and so and I think honestly in Triathlon
it's you know certainly I've never ever
felt at the highest level you know when
you get to Kona you know that you can't
compete you know I mean the level is
like wow okay I'm either good enough or
I'm not you know and and I think so I
think Iron Man does
quite a good job of controlling the
athletes particularly at the Pinnacle
you know I mean you know you've I've
heard you know sometimes in other races
there's some crazy results but often
those guys never show up to Kona you
know or you know and that's so that's
sort of right sort of fine
um but but I guess what I'm what I'm
getting at is
the athletes that have you know
yes which is a culture show which is a
culture shift which is or I think is
fantastic you know and that'll be all
better than just the testing getting
better exactly the test is trying to
figure out how do we keep up because
let's face it I mean I've obviously
never had an issue and and obviously
touch what I never do I wouldn't as I
said I wouldn't know why or how but
I remember I remember when I went to
liquid gas and and they asked me my
blood type I said I'll have to call my
mum and they laughed you know because
that was obviously just after the end of
like a blood doping era you know Puerto
blown up and and I didn't even know my
blood type they knew how would you not
know that yeah how would you not if you
were involved in that sort of thing and
so
it's uh yeah I mean so it's only the
athletes that can get that can really
control it and and fortunately we're as
a collective we've we've all decided to
do it the right way and and
um and I think that's you know very
commendable and the the do is your sense
that the the passports are effective as
a deterrent yeah absolutely it's a
deterrent because there's definitely
been guys that have fought it and won
and these guys that have gone down so
you know that if there's something off
you could get done so that's for sure a
deterrent I mean personally I don't
think oh this is a test for my passport
or you know because I I wouldn't even
know you get tested often so it's you
know Here There and Everywhere as far as
where your tests go whether it's just a
random or a passport test or I mean
every test is recorded but there's
certain ones that are for your passport
not I mean when I rock up to Kona they
actually test me twice for some reason
because they test me for the cycling
passport which is different to what you
know Triathlon has doubling up on your
testing yeah yeah I got done twice
probably every year and and the fact
that you were an Olympic rower like
you've been getting tested for as long
as yeah like you might be the most
tested oh for sure I'd say 100 I am
because coming from Tasmania too there
was I think seven Olympians that year
and I was the youngest and the the the
the what like the atoms so the
whereabout system which was quite broad
at first it was basically like where do
you live great okay and you you put that
in a system and they might find you
obviously in Tasmania it was pretty easy
for the lady to find me she went to
school with my mum and the whole you
know
she'd pop up and knew when I was home
she called mum and oh it's Cameron up
too oh okay great yep oh we'll I'll see
you in a couple of weeks and um but it
was quite but but I was on there from
the very beginning of that system
of that passport system when I was
rowing and even still up until uh I mean
obviously now I'm testing for both
sports but I never ever got taken off
the rowing one I mean it's only been a
few years since I actually had a rowing
test as well like I was getting randomly
tested yeah
this is many years after that yeah the
association yeah well I guess because
I'm on the national Federation it's just
rowing's listed as a sport still because
I never like officially retired or
whatever from it and so yeah technically
they can still test me for that but it's
interesting now because you have this
be shift you know with supplementation
and different things and and I guess the
biggest one that you know is like the
big talking point now I mean okay you've
had painkillers different things but
it's like ketones you know and and and
for a long time we know they've been
around a long time you know we know
they've been around for I don't know 10
12 years or something guys have been
experimenting off and on I was first
made aware of them Nike you know
presented some to me um the hvmn ones
back in 2019 uh-huh
um I couldn't even get a bottle down you
know so vile and we got it yeah we kind
of scrapped it and then and and also it
was sort of like a bit taboo you know
like no one really knew where the gray
lion and whatever was and then now but
as we know you know in the last couple
of years it's become well in the Peloton
it's quite Rife
um I know Tim O'Donnell is a big
proponent he's been on the Show
sponsored by Delta G yeah another
another one of the the big companies and
so there's there's been this this sort
of shift to now a couple of the teams
have actually come out and said okay
we're sponsored by X brand and I don't
know there's quite a number of different
brands
um and which means that all of a sudden
that has sort of passed the ethical
point but for a long time that was like
a top secret because no one really it
probably gives you an idea of how
you know fragile everyone was on this
whole anti-doping thing because you
weren't cheating they weren't illegal
they were verified they were fine but no
one would talk about it interesting you
know I thought that was it any else
there was a team that that was sort of
you know testing and experimenting with
this and using it in braces that was
interesting because they said it was
ineos but when I was sent them in 19 Tim
said listen like we we're not doing that
you know we don't do that here and and
that was like okay well they taste
horrible so that's fine but then you
know the last couple of years I've I and
to be honest I I wasn't presented with
it from the team but I became aware of
certain groups within the team were on
program you know trial programs with it
and I've been racing and seen other
teams pulling them out of their pocket I
mean I remember this race mid race I was
riding on the front with Tim de clerk
from from Quick Step and he pulled out
one of the hvm bottles you know I
remembered it and cracked the top and
hoofed it down how'd you do that but
they they believe it's quite a wonder
drug you know I mean it's got a bunch of
different you know functions cognitive
and obviously ability to utilize your
fuels and everything better
um yeah I I've personally started using
it while I've been here in this Camp
just to get my own understanding of it
you know away from the team and away
from to to learn
and to learn a bit about it I've the the
hvmm one which is now a very different
formula which is much more palatable and
and I guess I find that yeah you can it
almost does feel like
it's I can see why everyone kept it a
secret because you you feel like you can
train harder you know like you feel like
you're on the limit like you know and
but all of a sudden you can still do it
you know whereas before you felt like
you would blow up you know like you
start that interval and you think right
I don't know if I'll get through this
one and sure enough it's too much
whereas all of a sudden now you've
you've you've still got that bit and and
every day you get to your rest day and
you're like you know what like I'm not
that tired like I mean last last week I
yeah I had a long run I was telling you
about you know I've been communicating
with Ken Ridout and I thought right you
know what I think I'll run a marathon
today so all right Ken has that yeah has
that ability so I go out and I run I run
and I have a bit of a caveat I grabbed
the dog for the last three or four K to
slow it right down so that I don't you
know so I ran like 248 pays for 38 39K
grabbed the dog and jogged in at like
six minute K pay so we did a 254. so
just a nice cruisy little marathon and
normally that for you you know you feel
pretty average the next day got up for
my easy day you know it was beautiful
got on the gravel bike ended up you know
going for a swim so four and a half
hours later I get home and then the next
day I was doing threshold efforts on the
bike you know and to think that like you
could
you know
trained at that level like I couldn't
fathom doing that even before Kona it
does feel like it's in this weird
liminal space between what's okay and
what might not be okay exactly a bit
that's that's my point with this exactly
with the ketones it's like and we've had
a number of years where people have been
very unsure of it to the point where
it's kept secret right whereas
exactly because it's like almost like
the world's best kept secret you know in
in in sport and and um and it's mate but
now and I don't know if people are
coming out about it because they're like
well we've actually we're actually way
ahead of the research now with it and
we're comfortable to tell people about
it so they can use it that way but we're
actually using it in this capacity well
it's the only reason it's the most
widely talked about thing yeah and it's
it's it's it's something that only in
the past year has become commercially
available yeah yeah exactly and that's
been a big barrier to it I mean yeah
most of them are incredibly expensive
and I think that's like age Fair men's
different is is there becoming they're
trying to make it so it is accessible to
people with a different you know formula
I guess that is cheap to create and and
time will tell how how that goes I mean
it's probably the only way it will
become widespread is if it becomes
affordable and accessible to people you
know that they can buy it at the
supermarket and you know now you've got
to go and you've got to probably get
online you've got to actually maybe do
some research because it has that stigma
attached to it
um but
I mean there's it's crazy I mean
obviously like with anything new there's
always like studies and everything and
and and it seems to be able to benefit
everything
um so anyway with sport
you know all of a sudden we've
transcended to a point where okay we've
got stuff that we know is legal yet we
don't know if we should say anything
about it which is quite mind-boggling
when you think back to how sport used to
be so I think that's a positive you know
right right and hopefully not a signal
of Are We pushing again to like are we
going back are we going back Darkness
okay ketones are fine but but what's
their next you know like people thinking
okay if that's helping that and you know
what can we you know keep pushing keep
pushing the the boundary
um and I know with our team
we felt like other teams have been at
the Forefront of these particularly
ketones and
um research and and use
and and we've been apprehensive because
of the stigma and sort of Left Behind
for a period and obviously felt like we
need to get on board you know
um so
yeah the sport definitely took a big hit
yeah absolutely you know and and uh and
I think it's great that everyone is so
conscious about
now we're conscious about stuff that's
perfectly legal let's take a bit and
really try to understand what this is
before we just say yes yeah yeah I mean
collagen was another one you know I mean
years ago you know it was like is that
okay is it not you know it's you know
and all of a sudden now that's
everywhere do you have to be
uh real I mean obviously you do you have
to be super conscious of everything you
put in your body yeah you have a
supplement regimen or do you have to
have to make sure everything's NSF and
all of that so that you don't end up
with a you know some kind of false
positive tainted yeah situation
absolutely I mean I just make sure it's
um uh I'm not sure what the there's a
little logo that I know to look for yeah
it's like a little circle or something
yeah yeah so right yeah and um yeah I
mean I to be to be honest this is
something else I've I've mean my wife is
holistic nutrition so she's big on food
you know and that being everything and
and up until recently that's been the
big Focus for us you know
um is is trying to give me everything
through that but
yeah we've done some research now and
like you know for example collagen you
know for the joints especially I am 39
so I am getting older not that I feel I
mean I'm doing more than I've ever done
but I need to stay on top of it
um so yeah that's something that I've
implemented
um vitamin C just purely for you know
immunity I just don't want to get sick
and
I don't know if it's uh Placebo but I
find whenever I'm religious with just a
couple of vitamins c a day I'm able to
stay you know healthy
um obviously now the ketones and that
seems to be you know having some benefit
um and then yeah I mean one of my one of
my the companies I'm involved with
momentous they have a sleep which sleep
pack which uh we're traveling a huge
amount you know I mean the going against
your psychotic Rhythm and everything
else like trying to manage that process
is
um is really important I think into the
longevity in the sport all the time
changes but also to get the most out of
your performance but I've also found
that because of its Effectiveness with
that and I feel I've been able to travel
better this you know the last sort of
few months that I've been using it
um when I have a hard day and I want to
make sure I get a good night's sleep I
have that too but you know I wake up and
you know it's all natural and that's the
great thing about momentous everything's
all natural Etc so even in our household
my wife who was you know very much
against you know numbers and chemical
you know all this sort of stuff we've
started to devise you know a bit of a
protocol of different things because
there's enough science out there that
you know suggests that it's it's
potentially good for you to get the most
out of yourself yeah the momentous sleep
pack I think it's called Sleep Elite
yeah because what it's called like I use
that and uh you know they're a supporter
of the show and I know Jeff and all of
that like we're stoked to be working
with them and I really love their
products so I I use that as well but
there's also like the huberman protocol
which is all like the l-theanine like so
I'll take that occasionally but then I
get crazy dreams yeah I don't know yeah
it happens to you like yeah no it starts
to weird me out yeah yeah no I I used to
back in the old days when we had like
Temazepam and still knocks and crazy
things like that with like the cycling
team but even that stuff is not out
there anymore you know it's melatonin's
about as extensive as it gets from from
from the team
um and then of course yeah you're basic
like protein I mean for me like that's a
big one like that really you know
especially I generally actually have it
between a session you know I don't have
it at the end of the day
um like because generally whenever I
finish one thing I've still got
something else yeah and oh in the
morning I'll I'll Brew up I've got an
American type coffee maker at home and I
make a big pot and I have a you know a
couple or two before I head out for
training and then if I've got to run or
swim or something in the afternoon you
know I get home I throw the frozen
banana I throw the protein or the
recovery powder in there nice good Scoop
of very healthy Nutella natural of
course and um and as the base oh some
ice I'll use the coffee you know and if
it's later in the day I might use almond
milk or rice milk or something else but
it's like a protein bomb I call it and
so I'm getting my you know I'm starting
the recovery process from the session I
did before but I've still actually got
another one to go but I'm getting a
boost from the from the the recovery
yeah and I know like we started this
podcast at like five o'clock and you
drank an espresso yeah which is a bold
move yeah yeah no well you probably
already what did you already do today so
you went out and rode with G all day
today right yeah we did four and a half
hours I did I did a couple of as I said
a couple of sort of zone three efforts
which you know Zone threes around that
150 to 1 60 sort of heart rate so you
know as I said to GE I said it's sort of
like it's not hard but it's not easy you
know it's in that middle Zone it's sort
of like annoying because you're kind of
holding back but not too much you know
it's actually a bit easier to go a bit
harder so yeah I ended up doing a couple
of 20 minutes is around 410 watts and
then uh shot home
um put on the running shoes and did a
couple of two and a half K around three
twenty three Thirty Pace you know a bit
of you know cruisy jogging in between
that bit over 15K in an hour 15 and a
half k
so uh yeah that was that's sort of a
typical yeah it was about five wow yeah
it was about five and a half hours in
total so how does that work
with Garrett like does that [__] with
his head because this is a guy who's won
the Tour de France and you're the guy
who's training with him but you're doing
more by going out after the training
session that you do with him and then
going to swim or rust so this was
something we didn't get to but Tim
Garrison this is I think he's a
mastermind because
that kind of happened at first and in 18
and then after the first week and
obviously fumi figured it out pretty
quick you know in 17 when we're together
so what happens is they just do more so
G you know when we came out here in 18
which is the first time we really
trained just one-on-one after about a
week he I said oh mate I you know I'm
I'm just running a bit late this morning
um and oh but I you know and he's so
anyway when we got this oh everything
okay I was like yeah no I'm fine I just
had swimming and he just didn't he's
like you've what so all of a sudden the
next day you know he was up you know an
hour and a half two hours earlier yeah
yeah this is not to understand and then
every time I said okay yeah I'm finished
now he's like yeah I'm gonna just go up
here so even today you know we got to we
got to Sunset he said yeah I'm actually
going to go up behind the Palisades to
that one-way climbing back but I'd
already said I'm going home to get my
shoes on so I couldn't do the extra with
him plus the run so and there's
definitely been you know Tim Carris that
I think has been a bit of a mastermind
and now the guys are trained with you
know now the younger guys Tom Peacock
make me Sheffield
Etc
they all you know okay well I might I'd
like you know Tom for example you know
he in Andorra we get you know the main
town and then it sort of splits there's
up the French Valley and up the Spanish
Valley and I live on the Spanish sort of
Valley side and that's where the pool is
and so to then get over to the French
side you either will keep going up there
or you have to climb a big mountain pass
like climbing up and over
um Latigo for example you know good you
know thousand meters what's that three
three and a half thousand foot climb
yeah so Tom will say oh just come past
the pool with you because then you know
he's actually got to go past the pool
and then all the way up and over the
climb before he gets home so it's uh
yeah I think it's I think it's good for
them yeah who's gonna get the the last
word in basically exactly exactly and
it's uh and yeah as long as we're all
performing that's the main thing I love
that that you guys are like cruising
around La like I think it's this is a
drum that I'm always beating but I just
think it's the most underrated place to
train I mean maybe it's not Andorra but
when you look at triathletes and how
many people are in Boulder and I was
joking with Timothy O'Donnell like you
guys are all in your garages and in your
basement it's like on treadmills and and
it was like 84 degrees here today
boiling today yeah for me I said to the
guys and fermi's obviously come out you
know
he was here yeah like and a whole teams
well Colombia like just down the way
here like the hotel would just get you
know world world you know teams from the
the tour will come out and spend a month
or a couple weeks I say to the guy I
mean it's the wow factor here you know I
mean you people don't I mean and that
was the big reason why Tim was pushing
another part with me with G because I
lived here I knew my way around so from
day one he was able to we were able to
go on train if you don't know the place
yet you'd get to Orlando all right where
do I go right you didn't you wouldn't
know like it's not obvious that it's a
good place no and but once you get out
there like today you know just up on
Saddle Peak there's four different sides
we went up every single side and I think
we saw about three cars and one of them
was the guy following us Marco so it's
just you know it's it's impossible to
explain it with one of the most densely
populated cities in the world that you
can see you know and then at the moment
after the rain and the wind you know you
can see all that to the Catalina like
you almost feel like you can see Hawaii
I mean you just see for it's just it's
just the wow factor is nuts but the
quality of the of the climbing and the
training is I mean obviously you know to
bring him up but man chance I mean he
was the only one I know of that spent
time here training right in the in the
summer you know in the winter so that's
because he was dating Cheryl Crow it was
yeah he had reasons to be out here but
still he was obviously really smart you
know he knew he knew where to go
um and and the weather you know it's you
you get up in the morning you never have
to question can you do this okay we've
had like two days of rain and it was
Armageddon but
you'd never have to question it like and
that is the hardest thing for me here is
a rest day because again you feel like
you should be doing something you know
the last thing of the world you feel
like you should be doing is resting and
doing nothing but then that's great
being here you can go Disneyland or go
see a game or go to go do something else
but uh yeah I mean yesterday for example
I just was in the Hollywood Hills up and
down all day you know I mean I did a
hundred well about 70 miles and I didn't
leave Suburbia right you know and just
going up and down from Mulholland yeah
doing various yeah the roads that go up
there yeah up in you know sunset
Outpost down the end Nichols Canyon
um I mean there's there's actually
hundreds of them in there you know a
little like Loma Vista like all these
hidden little brick walls you know but
last 10-15 minutes like proper climbs
but it you know 20 right it's a good
perch I mean so they're not going to be
as long or as steep as you're going to
get in Europe or in Boulder and you
don't have that altitude and all of that
but but the trade-off is year-round
climate exactly and especially this time
of the year and
you know for G and and also for me I
mean things have worked out pretty well
since we've you know yeah do the
foundation work here you know like you
you just I think you just get a real leg
up by just being able to log those days
after days I mean that's the that's the
key to anything is consistency how come
more don't live out here you think yeah
to be honest I got no idea you know I
mean I think it's just uh
a stigma attached with the place like it
you know it just isn't for that and so I
guess with regard to professional
cycling though we're in Europe you know
we have to be in most guys are European
base but it's funny you say it because
there's actually a couple of guys in the
world who are now that are actually from
here uh Sean Quinn with ef and um Kevin
vomac he's from down in Long Beach so
not quite but Sean Quinn I mean he grew
up on up in the Hollywood Hills on on
Mulholland oh wow yeah so he knows all
those roads like the back of his hand
and um and so they're young they're only
just going into the world tour they're
both very good and it could be you know
they could be the Catalyst for you know
other particularly Americans you know
setting up a base here and using it as
when they're not in Europe but um yeah
and then triathletes uh same sort of
thing I don't know it just doesn't have
the culture you know I mean Chris
McCormick was here for a while but
that's really all I know of well he
would come so like 10 12 years ago he
would come out and he would stay in
Hidden Hills yeah family there yeah
maybe you know the same people yeah like
they open up their home and he would he
would stay there and uh and and then
terenzo also zoning would come out yeah
and I would swim with those guys every
day and train with them oh wow uh like
we would swim at the Calabasas swim and
that's like my local pool okay
yeah work out with those guys and they
were the only ones yeah
um and we would have the same
conversation yeah but I think if the one
thing that's missing is a 50 meter
outdoor pool like if you're out here in
Agora or whatever if they put something
like that in yeah attract you know yeah
I mean there's one obviously out of
Pasadena yeah
to drive from the Santa Monica Mountains
and and the college out here they got it
set up in yards a lot of the time and
yeah yeah I don't I really don't know uh
because uh to me this place is just
I mean it's just so stimulating and
endurance sport is I won't say hard
because I love it but it is you know I
mean there's there's times when it's
like especially in Andorra it's cold in
the morning it's dark you know and it's
tough to get dressed and roll out the
door I mean once you get out there it's
like fresh Mountain Air and altitude and
you know all the guys around you know
this is like during winter obviously
summer it's beautiful but but here
yeah you just can't wait to get out
where am I going to go you know it's
like not a case of oh I have to go this
it's like it's hard to choose you know
the options of that endless of
everywhere where you want to be that
it's actually difficult to choose where
to go like running like my Marathon the
other day hardest thing was trying to
figure out which which part I'm going to
add first and where when am I going to
go down to the beach and do the Rocky
Run part and up to Muscle Beach and then
up around Brentwood and you know like
trying to just just oh it's just great I
love it here I love that you love it
um I do want to ask you what you've
learned like how does like how does what
you know or what you learned as a rower
contribute to uh your cycling and your
Triathlon and vice versa like how does
your expertise in all of these various
disciplines inform like how you train
and race there has to be some alchemy
between all of those sports that make
you kind of a more informed experienced
athlete yeah well definitely in Rome
doing learning how to get the most out
of a team because it's even more extreme
than cycling you know because if you go
off on your own tangent the boat won't
go anywhere and one thing I was very
good at in rowing I may never have been
the best guy I was very good at rowing
with other people we do a thing called
speed order trials where you it's seat
racing where you you know they just
change one guy so I might be a double or
a four and they'll two together and put
another pull him out put him with him
and you get a ranking and I would always
win that you know I could and it's
because I didn't have an ego I could
feel what the other guy was doing adapt
to that a lot of guys would get in just
do their thing and that was fine if they
were with me because I could adapt but
when they're getting with someone else
so they're meant to be great with the
you know completely sucks so in cycling
you know being able to identify you know
when guys are on the edge or when you
need to give someone a bit of a pep pep
me up or a bit of self-belief or or
whatever else because as I said you know
everyone's quite
quite capable so I think that part of
rowing you know has been a great uh a
great a great thing to learn
um and then I guess as far as how it's
helped me in Iron Man
you know I think just that ability to do
those big days in training you know like
I said I learned that from rowing I used
to but not only but not only did I do
the six hours I did it in three
different things like I said to you I'd
I'd go wrong I go to the gym I'd go for
a ride or I might go for a run so I've
been doing that forever it's not like I
just started it you know I mean you you
the things that I I believe the things I
draw on now are things I did as like a
17 16 17 18 year old kid you know the
foundation was was set and uh I've just
been able to draw into that you know
with anything that I've done
um over that over that period of time so
I'd say in rowing okay you've got the
Natural Things pushing yourself hurting
yourself you know trying to training
hard the discipline you know of you know
with rowing you you have no choice but
to turn up to training because otherwise
the boat doesn't go in the water so
there's other guys there that can't
train if you don't show up punctuality
like we say we're going to be together
at this time that's where we are and and
I'm always you know there's there's guys
that are like oh yeah I'm 10 minutes
late I'm and I'm like and I get a bit
edgy about that I mean not enough but I
you know you calm down you say something
to them but to me that's not acceptable
because in rowing you can't get on the
water whereas in cycling obvious like
whatever you know yeah have another
coffee and wait you know
um so
and that's uh that's some you know the
discipline side of it is is great to
learn and and not to let anyone down and
um and I guess another I was I was
speaking to someone recently about you
know enrolling every race is a big race
and important you know like you don't
race a lot you train a lot and then you
get your national championships you get
your selection trials we've got to make
the national team you go to the World
Cups and the world Champs like they're
all big
in cycling you have you're racing all
the time yeah and you've got to be able
to and a lot of the time like that tour
next week UAE for example you know three
or four of the days of Sprint days and
we're sort of there with a GC team for
the climb so it's like okay that's just
not crash save some energy because
tomorrow we've got a freaking absolutely
feed it to her you know there's a team
time trial or whatever
so getting that around you around your
head that it's not that way was actually
a challenge for me because and I used to
crash a lot I guess because every day I
was desperate but in triathlon
it's wonderful that I learned that skill
because every time I race a triathlon
it's important you know I want to win
you know I'm there to perform you know
and and uh so I've I'm used to I've got
the experience of that from from rowing
you know it's like everyone matters and
that's I never go to a race say
I never want to be I never want people
to come and watch and go God Cameron
didn't even try or you know this like I
want everyone to go wow that was great
to watch him no matter what the result
yeah you know yeah that's that's really
interesting I mean I think what I what I
what I take from your example or or kind
of what inspires me about
your path is
that
um
you know it's really about
the enthusiasm that you have like you're
in love with what you do right like it's
so clear like you're just you're so
excited like you're you're not like I
gotta get up and do that like you're
look looking forward to whatever
punishment you're gonna Dole out on
yourself tomorrow right like you can't
wait I can't you know and and that's
cool because you've been doing it for so
long and as somebody who's been you know
at the highest level of sports it's like
what 2004 or something like that like
the fact that well still a champion in
2003 okay
well we'll throw a couple more years on
there 22. yeah yeah but uh all right so
even even more impressive then you know
I don't want to shortchange you no
um
and you're still getting better and
you're still improving yeah but I think
that's a function of how much you're
enjoying yourself which I think gets
lost you know and and probably I think a
lot of professional athletes after
they've been in it for a while they just
you it's it's easy to get cynical or to
kind of lose what got you excited about
being in the sport to begin with and
somehow you've been able to hold on to
that yeah but I I as back to what we
said before I surround I've been very
fortunate with the people I'm surrounded
with They Don't Really allow me to
and and they don't really allow me to
think in any other way you know I mean
Tim Garrison is never like oh God we're
starting to fall off here we need to do
this try and keep you up there we need
to keep you in the game it's all okay
we've got to get this swim Block in
we've really got to figure this out okay
you've been making excuses for however
long right we've finally got this 50
meter pool let's go you know let's go
and do these big Miles because that's
all you've got to do it's really simple
and and Brett Kirby at Nike you know the
fascinating thing last year they said
listen
you know we got an idea how what do you
think about La Olympics and I was like
yeah what do I think I think it's
fantastic it's 2028 said yeah you'll be
44.
how about you try and go back to rowing
I was going to get to this I was going
to get to this but go ahead yeah and and
I and I said far out okay yeah I hadn't
really thought of that but they're like
wow it'd be great to like bookend your
career with you know with that Sport and
it's such a vast you know Gap in between
and I said okay well I'll be 44. now
another thing is Tom Brady and I both
born on the 3rd of August obviously he's
older than me but we're born on the 3rd
of August so since he started all this
longevity stuff I always had like 45 is
that you know this this number and so
Nike did a bit of research and you know
it seems that physiologically as long as
you look after yourself you haven't had
injuries Etc you shouldn't really
decline until then you know I mean
there's a lot of evidence particularly
it's like your VO2 for example is the
first thing to get hit and it won't
really go until then
um so the first thing that could
potentially be affected would be
swimming and running which are the two
things that I could still improve the
most in because I just simply haven't
done them for that long and then cycling
actually comes even later right so
and they said the reason most guys get
to mid 30s early 30s and think it's time
to stop is they've been doing that for
20 years like you change your mind like
you change your underpants about sports
so you know you never give yourself a
chance to have got complacent or you
know I mean even look at you now you got
into Iron Man now all of a sudden you
wanted to throw cycling back in there
and you're constantly trying to figure
out how to be how to be better how to
figure it out and so you know if we
threw rowing at you it would only do the
same thing you'd be like right I'm back
in the boat okay how can all these years
of every other sport
apply to to making that happen and it
sounds like Coastal rowing will be will
be part of the Olympics and they call
that old man's rowing right so like
again on that like foreign like
everything's just showing up with
perfect timing like yeah yeah
potentially sport like because all the
young Gunners are not going to go for
that they want to be in the skulls right
so it most likely opens it up yeah for
you you'd think the first Olympics if
there's a shot you know breaking I mean
G and I talked about this because we've
always joked about he's always joked
about wanting to the line man it was he
wanted to do it competitively but then
he's seen what's happened in the sport
and you know he said I said mate look if
I'm honest with you if you've done it
when I started that was I guess kind of
low hanging fruit you know I came in was
able to kind of change things and
all that really you know everything when
I learned to run there was a lot of
great cyclists before but no one could
run but when I learned to run they all
learned to ride you know and still run
as quick to stay ahead of me you know
and the low-hanging fruits kind of gone
from the sport now you know you got
these with all due respect but you know
I was able to make my way in at a time
when there was an opportunity to do that
and so and so now G's more like yeah you
know I'm just going to enjoy when I stop
cycling I'm gonna do Iron Man whales
maybe qualify for Kono maybe be an age
group you know do as well as I can and
um and who knows from there but and I
guess that's the same thing with Coastal
rowing you know it'll be the first
Olympics that'll be in
so we'll see it might not be as
competitive but at the end it gets
longer right like what is the distance
yeah like five six K so it's like 25 to
30 minutes depending on the weather
um and yeah on the conditions and
obviously with now having some Open
Water Swimming understanding and you
know with the with the rowing I've got
access to obviously the the work the
America's Cup crew so I could go and
maybe spend some time with them to learn
a bit about you know currents and water
and you know wind and you know different
things that I never thought of before
um I guess I potentially do have the
resources around me too you do give that
a nudge that's but we'll see because I
didn't even think of the whole inios
thing and how they can you know come to
your you know Aid with all of that like
that's insane I mean that would just you
have to do that like it would just be
absolutely [__] legendary
yeah I hey I mean I won't rule it out I
mean I definitely won't rule it out I
mean it would just be indisputed like
yeah legendary status yeah and being
here in La that's going to be yeah and I
think once we get through Paris next
year and I'm not really look I mean I
haven't given up on obviously with my
role in the team there's always a role
on the Australian team and we've
discussed it in the past few years even
leading up to Tokyo I was in the sort of
the group but you know I was a few guys
away from getting picked and even bit
the worlds each year like you know since
what I did last year particularly in
rubai I guess that kind of reminded
everyone you know that I can play that
role and at the highest level and and
and also maybe I could help bring the
team together a bit you know like
obviously national teams it can be quite
fragmented with different trade teams
and they all come together so who knows
so you know you never know what might
happen with Paris but it's definitely
not like an objective my my goal in the
next two years is to be the best
teammate I can be you know with the guys
this year and I mean I take that year by
year whether I'm going to race again
um as I said I came very close to being
happy not to do it this year but the
team sort of encouraged me to keep going
and I'm happy I made that call I really
want to win in nice you know obviously
it's at the end of the day it is a world
championship and it's an opportunity to
win any you know if I can pull that off
obviously I want to confirm it in Kona
and and then we'll see you know right I
can't see myself bidding Iron Man I
think even if I did Coastal rowing I'd
probably want to do both
um but they probably complement each
other
exceptionally well so um
yeah we'll see and then longer term I
mean like the multi-sport ultra world
you would just absolutely dominate that
well I I turned your sights on that
after that the the Pod with Colin I I
you know I started following I think
actually Ultra the world championship in
Kona was on around that time
uh you're talking about Ultraman yeah I
was there I was there I crewed an
athlete at that race okay yeah so I
teach here I did take note of that and
you did that you would absolutely Crush
that race well yeah I I kind of feel
that and what they're doing is
incredible but I kind of feel like uh
uh you know someone Tim O'Donnell or
yeah somebody somebody legit has to step
up and tackle that or Ben Hoffman and
they're going to blow it out of you know
they're going to do something a bit like
what's happening in Iron Man I mean it's
not it's not inevitable it's not
critical to the guys doing it they're
amazing I mean they're the best in the
sport but there's there's going to be
something that'll push them you know
like has happened in in in Iron Man you
know and and it's sort of been a natural
evolution of getting bigger and bigger
and all of a sudden now Iron Man is like
you say it's like a race we're sprinting
yeah almost so what's going to challenge
challenge us next okay doing doing it
twice right yeah yeah I mean it's
starting to change this year uh Leander
cave and Dede griesbauer had a bit of a
race and Dede like was amazing oh yeah I
think she's 52 you know so yeah and
still like I mean it was her performance
was Unreal yeah um but to get somebody
more in their Prime to step in and do
that yeah you know I think it's only a
matter of time it definitely yeah I I I
like to look at that as well yeah it
should yeah yeah yeah you're not you're
not headed back to the the real estate
fund anytime yeah I know as I said
that's gonna be more we love you but
like I think that that seat might be
fallow yeah a little bit longer no he he
knows that and he'll be he'll be a big
supporter like he said to me you your
role in this whole fund is Walkabout if
you can take us on your Walkabout you
know
um one thing that I've been you know
I've always you know I've not to Pat
myself on the back but I tend to always
put everyone else first you know even
and that's great like I said in rowing
like I always want to be the bottom guy
in the team I always want to make
everyone else better I'm always happy
for everyone else when they win
that doesn't always work out best for
you right in the sports the fact that
you're so committed to Kona tells me
that you yes and you also you don't
desire yeah absolutely want your moment
and in that one though it doesn't really
affect everyone else you know it's it's
like it's just me but obviously with the
team even with and so I guess Finance
has always drawn me in because I think
well here's an industry where you can
you know want what's best for everyone
else you want to help make money and
then that's also going to benefit you
quite handsomely so so it's um it's
definitely it's definitely something
that I think will fit nicely you know as
I said I've and and the fact that
everything I've done I've always wanted
to be around the best people or found
myself around the best people and wanted
to succeed I you know I mean until I
take my last breath I hope I maintain
that attitude with everything I do yeah
yeah yeah
um well we we gotta wrap this up here
but before we do that I I think I think
uh you know it would be helpful
to just leave the The Listener or the
viewer with
um a few thoughts on
um you know helping them with their own
kind of Fitness endurance journey I mean
I think it's easy to hear your story and
find it inaccessible you know but you
know you're racing when you do these
Iron Mans you're with all the amateurs
you're seeing what everybody's doing
what they're doing right what they're
doing wrong yeah um so for the aspiring
triathlete or endurance athlete or
somebody who's training for their first
marathon like
based upon your experience and kind of
what you see other people doing like
what are some you know things to focus
on and things to maybe not focus on are
common mistakes that you see yeah um
it's funny because a friend of mine a a
Rob with him out here Stuart Walton and
he's his wife Kelly they're actually
training for a half Ironman yeah it's
like and they've never done one and
we've had a lot of these conversations
lately and I always say the same thing
to people
focus on the swim and I seem very
hypocritical because it you know I'm not
the best at it myself but and I and I
don't seem to apply the time to it and I
should but if you don't get out of that
swim well the rest of the day is a
really long long day so if you're a
great swimmer okay then you could move
to the bike you know and then once you
can get through the bike
and then you can start thinking about
the run but but to me like the biggest
thing is and I think people neglect it
you know like I'm not a good swimmer
it's like well honestly the more time
you spend and you just work on that so
you can just get through that
comfortably you're gonna mean that you
can actually utilize the things you are
strong at you know much much better
throughout the rest of the race so
that's always my my biggest piece of
advice and then another thing you know
we discussed was you know he was talking
to me about the you know the boots and
the gun you know all this sort of stuff
and
I mean honestly like especially if
you're
that stuff takes time I mean I don't
know the Norwegians talked about it
really well like about massage and but
it's so true you know I mean all that
stuff takes time it can often take time
away from things that you'd prefer to be
doing and does it really help that much
that lip probably not you know and not
to not to crap can on any of that stuff
but especially when you're time
crunching you have a life like exactly
living you know the life that Gustav and
Christian have no and even though you
don't have the time they have like you
have a wife and a child exactly yeah I I
when I heard them I was like wow I
remember being at the Institute oh yeah
I don't say I miss those days I love
what I've got now but yeah I could I
could just picture them yeah you can see
it but you know don't and people feeling
bad that I haven't you know done my
boots or my you know ball or my whatever
it is you know like make sure you have a
good meal you know eat well you know I
mean uh taking extra time to do that or
or just you know if you're watching TV
just have a stretch or you know whatever
like work those little bits of extra
pieces in you know around you know just
making sure you've you the rest of your
life's going along well because if you
let all those little bits and pieces get
on top of you you know that'll then get
on top of your training and the rest of
life and to make it you know very
difficult yeah so I'd say you know
really simplify things but
but then I just go back to what you
asked me about what separates yeah okay
Sun Yang was a controversial example but
you know for me G Etc
Christian you know the guys it's you
know okay I'm not saying go out and run
a marathon but maybe at least spend
three hours on your feet walking and
jogging or something you know before you
have a crack at an Iron Man one day and
and and Run and Ride definitely try and
ride 180 kilometers you know like just
to see you can see how it feels and
obviously swim the distance like just go
through the motions you'd be amazed the
how much confidence that will give you
knowing that you've done it other than
getting there on the start line you know
I mean there'll be times when it's just
not possible because of your lifestyle
and you do what you can but you know if
you can make the time just for that even
if it's just one you know and I'm not
saying do it all in one day I'm saying
you know one weekend okay I'm gonna do
Race distance okay next weekend I'm
gonna ride the race distance the next
weekend I'm gonna hike for three hours
you know just just like
practice what you got to deal with you
know and uh I know that's all sounds
simple but unless you get the
foundations of it all right like the
training that you know the the intervals
the power meters the heart rate all that
stuff it's it's really largely
irrelevant you know I mean and even then
once you get to our level a lot of the
time you it's irrelevant you're just
trying to you've got to go that speed
and you've got to figure out how to do
it
um but yeah I mean swimming is a big one
and and finding a great group I mean
everyone says it but finding a squad is
is crucial I mean I swim a lot on my own
but you know that's more because of time
you know and when I have to fit training
in but when it works to swim with the
group I mean it's it's by far the best
way to go and especially if you're
learning and uh
it just keeps you accountable and
because you can waste a lot of time if
you don't have a structure when you're
trying to manage three different sports
so that accountability help helps a huge
amount so um yeah just those Basics I
hope that helps yeah no I think that's
great advice I mean there's anything
specific the only the the yeah the
corollary that I would add to that is
simply making it sustainable and trying
to make sure that you're enjoying it
right because otherwise like what the
[__] are you doing like it should be fun
and not like overly it should be hard
but yeah burdensome yeah and not in it
approach in a way that's going to
capsize the other things in your life
important to you yeah and on the topic
of swimming I think you know what I see
is
I mean the broader issue is we all like
to train our strengths and we don't
really want to deal with the stuff we're
not good at you know so we kind of avoid
it right in Triathlon that's often
swimming because people didn't grow up
swimming they're just they're not that
good at it they're intimidated whatever
and so they either avoid it and then
when they go to do it they're so intent
on getting their their Fitness in that
they won't take the time to learn and
understand techniques so I've seen so
many triathletes in the pool like they
got to get their K's in yeah they have
their workout but their form is terrible
yeah and I'm like you're just you should
just stop completely and like start over
and invest in really understanding how
to improve your Technique because you're
just you're literally you could get as
fit as you want you're still just
wasting all this energy and you're not
moving forward yeah you know but because
they're time crunch are like I can't
afford I can't you know afford that time
or that investment but that would pay a
massive dividend yes oh yeah swimming is
the one sport that
you can by having the two gung-ho
approach it can really backfire on you I
mean there's obviously some examples in
our sporting guys you know they've been
getting better at swimming for 10 years
and they train in 30 40 I mean at least
when I don't swim well it's because I
haven't swum yeah
shame on you for being Australian and
not having swimming be your strongest
exactly the three but yeah how dare you
intro I thought I mean it's always
that's the starting point you know get
that right and and like you say just
just learn how to float you know learn
how to learn how to comfortably get
through that swim and yeah and from
there on your uh
yeah worry about the rest right on yeah
um all right now well we gotta pull the
plug on this thing okay and you've got
to get to that the uh UAE yeah yeah no
no next week oh next week oh so you're
around still yeah yeah all right cheers
man thanks dude that was super fun honor
to be appreciated so if people want to
follow you uh in the upcoming season
where's the best place to find find you
on Instagram yeah that's all I've got
actually I don't have anything else so
yeah yeah I'm pretty I'm I mean I'm okay
at social media I have a decent
following I guess so yeah follow the
team and follow me and yeah there you go
what is the account at cam worth I think
it's CJ worth oh yeah it is right I'll
link it up in the show notes and all
that good stuff I appreciate that cool
man this is super fun yeah you're
welcome back and if you ever want to
ride really slow when you're here hey
we've got to go for that swim uh happy
to do it anytime now yes do it yeah cool
Cheers Cheers